salut salut à tous salut stuff ça fait
bien plaisir de te retrouver
super
je suis obligé d'avoir un parti pris un
chez 10 tout ouf avant le match
maintenant à rayon c'est un collègue de
club à Mulhouse au sein du top au sein
du Top 16 donc je suis obligé d'être
pour lui c'est c'est normal c'est normal
après j'aime beaucoup pas bien au
carwana pour moi ça a été pendant très
longtemps le numéro 2 derrière derrière
Magnus donc je pense que ça va être un
super match c'est on peut pas dire
l'ancienne école pour pour Fabiano mais
voilà c'est quand même la nouvelle la
jeunesse montante qui arrive donc à Rio
ne herigasi peut-être un des joueurs qui
a le plus progressé récemment dans les
top players tout tout jeune qui arrive
et pour défier les
Magnus pas bien non
trentenaire et autour quoi tu vois
ça peut changer je crois tout ça change
il me semble ça c'est roulant non un an
ah bon d'accord j'ai cru voir ça tout à
l'heure
ouais je te fais confiance comme ça on
voit que les joueurs ils sont pas aidés
par quelqu'un d'autre on voit que
maintenant c'est pro hein ils ont
plusieurs caméras chez eux et
apparemment tu es peut-être mieux ouf
si tu veux bien vérifier parce que
ça doit être Nathan qu'on salue
pourtant c'était hyper intéressant ce
que ce que tu avais dit stuff mais il y
a que moi qui en est profité quoi
c'était terrible
sur la cam sur laquelle de
Fabi je vais devoir la remettre parce
que du coup en fait ça m'a fait bugger
un petit peu le
comment dire
le zoom ils ont deux caméras chacun et
du coup
j'avais mis la première et il m'a enlevé
il m'a remplacé du coup je vais pouvoir
vous voyez qu'on a
plusieurs plusieurs formats plusieurs
cadences qui vont être proposés aux
joueurs donc là on est dans la première
session de 1h30 en 5 minutes plus une
seconde et ça c'est la cadence la plus
longue de la soirée
puisque après il y aura du 3 plus 1 et
après il y a le grand n'importe quoi en
1 + 1 le fameux Bullet ou stouf se
ferait un plaisir de m'écraser dans ce
genre de config déjà qu'en 5 + 1 et 3 +
5 je pourrais avoir du mal on sait bien
mais on a un plus sain là les pièces
volent vraiment très très vite il faut
être très réactif il faut avoir beaucoup
de réflexes et les joueurs normalement
ben on va bien se faire plaisir avec ce
type de cadence parce que ça va être
très très spectaculaire
donc du coup du coup trois cadences 5
plus une donc 5 + 6 en 1h30 on peut
attendre je pense à peu près 8 9 parties
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on espère et
ensuite on aura une heure deux trois
plus une et une demi-heure de Bullet
donc le Bullet bien sûr c'est ce qu'on
préfère ça va plus vite c'est plus sympa
et donc j'ai vu un petit peu les
pourcentages de victoires tu vois des
des joueurs ici
et en fait j'ai vu que les bookmakers
donnaient Fabien kervana
gagnant sur 67% du temps et ça c'est
bizarre
parce que en vrai moi j'aurais parié
j'aurais parié sur irigazi dans ce match
et a fait une super année 2022 il a
gagné plus de 100 points hello et il est
hyper hyper chaud alors que Kawana il a
plutôt une mauvaise année il a pas très
bien
je dirais en plus que les jeunes sont
favorisés par les cadrances courtes
c'est ce que je dirais stouf pour ça me
semble hyper logique quoi clairement et
en plus c'est vraiment la génération
Internet il fait beaucoup ça etc donc
exactement voilà intéressant et donc non
c'est vraiment un match un match hyper
intéressant
un peu intergénérationnel bon il est pas
très vieux Kawana mais là c'est vraiment
la nouvelle la nouvelle
génération qui arrive avec
rosacée
ils font ils font peur dans mon club de
Mulhouse on a trois qui sont devant on a
mis à le Sarine aussi Qui est qui est
très connu donc on a à Rio narguisi et
on a aussi Leon Luc mène donc à et du
coup c'est des joueurs qui sont qui sont
juste extraordinaires en équipe parce
qu'ils sont très combatifs et en plus ça
score ça score et ça progresse là ils
sont ils sont très très jeunes ils sont
déjà ils sont déjà un niveau
excellent et nous on a eu on a eu
quelques années le petit prince dans
notre équipe
30 à peu près et c'est déjà pas mauvais
14 ans il faisait il faisait peur et
j'étais Candy que maintenant à 2700
hello il fait encore plus peur
c'est encore plus peur mais après bon
maintenant tu as un peu moins à perdre
quand tu les joues parce que bon ils
sont tellement fort que ils ont déjà
prouvé vraiment
leur niveau tout ça quoi exactement donc
cool cool première partie hyper indécise
on a eu le droit à une structure on va
dire gamme deschanges et
du coup il y a une petite opportunité
peut-être de rater pour égaliser on a vu
un F5 est-ce que tu pourras m'enlever le
module c'est tout parce que sinon c'est
on a tendance
c'est pour ça que je peux dire ça hyper
facilement tu vois mais comme ça on le
verra pas donc on commente avec souffle
sans les modules comme ça bah on dit
humainement ce qu'on pense des positions
et c'est plus intéressant pour pour vous
qui suivait ce match et on va avoir
comme ça ce qui est palpable en tout cas
il y a maintenant une position qui est
assez équilibrée
on dit que le temps même dame cavaliers
ce comporte très bien et très
complémentaire pour l'instant les pièces
sont un peu mieux placées côté blanc et
on a vu le dernier coup d'âme des 8
l'idée Darius était de faire tout 8 et
de prendre la colonne la seule colonne
ouverte de l'échiquier
donc il y a peut-être un tout petit plus
noir encore que le fond en G2 est braqué
sur l'elda mais qui a quand même une
pression des pièces blanches sur l'aile
dame là on va voir comment on va
continuer sans doute que dame ça peut
permettre d'être Damas 3 aussi et
attention à la donnée du temps aussi
tout enfin très très important
ouais donc position qui est qui est
quand même assez intéressante moi j'aime
bien les blancs c'est quand même eux qui
jouent pour le pour l'avantage avec avec
le pion qui peut être passé et donc
avoir après c'est quand même assez assez
égal sans position tu vois je vois pas
un joueur scoré ici je sais pas ce que
tu en penses
je sais pas la structure est quand même
déséquilibrée pour le moment donc ça
peut encore laisser mais c'est vrai que
maintenant il faut trouver quelque chose
pour avancer pour les deux joueurs
encore trop tôt pour me prononcer je
prends pas de risque moi je souffre de
choses
je sais pas tout à l'heure je préfère un
petit peu les Noirs mais en même temps
pour progresser
si il va falloir manœuvrer avec le
cavalier il a joué pour des 7 et puis
après on peut peut-être manœuvrer avec
le cavalier puis et puis faire suer
l'adversaire ok tout droit reprise de
colonne on peut pas être partout
dame D8 tranquille
que j'ai l'impression qu'on va pouvoir
travailler peut-être avec
en train de terminer un petit réglage
c'est tout est prêt et dès que tu lances
le live et ben il y a tout qui se
dérègle avec l'entrée de tous les gens
dans le dans le zoom
mais là c'est ça arrive là je suis en
train de terminer j'ai quasiment fini
bon ça c'est propre déjà ce qu'on voit à
l'écran mais il y a d'autres scènes
aussi évidemment
ok donc ici cavalier 6
c'est normal pour 5e NAS de tout re 8
donc on peut pas prendre le pion C4
maintenant et peut-être un petit coup
malin quand même
voilà j'ai cette maintenant il y a plus
de 8 et on menace vraiment qu'elle prend
ses 4 donc là ce qu'on va voir fois sans
doute pour protéger le pion C4
évidemment C5 il y a les cavaliers C4
fourchettes
semble logique salut
toujours faire des paris avec Souf mais
t'inquiète pas on va en faire un on va
en faire un on est obligé d'ailleurs
tout fluip est venu payer ses dates sur
mon stream alors que moi pour l'instant
je l'ai laissé un petit peu je sais que
je lui envoie je vais lui en devoir
d'autre de toute façon c'est pour ça que
je passais de toute façon
c'est que le début c'est normal donc ok
donc
cavalez là donc dessin qui arrive ça y
est là on peut dire qu'il y a peut-être
une petite pressions
parce que finalement les blancs sont
mieux c'est pas sûr c'est une bonne
position pour se faire retourner
des six au final le fou et ben il fait
pas grand chose le foot le fou il est
mauvais il faut le dire
et donc s'il arrive pas à vraiment
mettre la présence sur les pions noirs
parce que là tu as B6 peut être joué
mais A5
c'est plus fort regardez comme c'est
malicieux il lui a piqué le pion et il
se dit bah maintenant trouve
et là fait mal à organiser avec ce
cavalier B6 croc A4 vous avez vu une
fourchette d'option et je pense que
Fabiano il emmène pas large
il doit être un peu du coup voilà
il doit aller vite si il joue pas
c'est le coup je voulais jouer sauf le
coup tranquille pour essayer de jouer
sur l'option adavant c'est pas se faire
enfler au niveau de son roi bon ça a
permis à
récupérer un pion c'est clair et
maintenant ah oui dame prend G4 on peut
jouer comme ça tu as pensé
c'est malin
et ta tête transitions speechess
souffrant d’été sur 20 ans c'est hyper
bon
et du coup
du coup dans cette position
et bien on fait
fait pas les mains avec les deux cons ça
c'est complètement
en venimeux cette position Dame des
cartes bien joué la dame hyper bien et
puis la finale maintenant elle est
prometteuse pour les Noirs quand même la
tour des ça te fait bien le travail
après c'est chaud c'est cadence là
tours 8
il peut y avoir des fois H3 aussi des
fois H3 en thème sauf je sais pas ce que
tu en penses
donc d'ailleurs il est venu à cavalier
[Musique]
inquiétant pour pour faire piano
blanche revient à un jeu ouais je fais
tourner 6 mais il y a tout recettes
tomber cette tour à 7 pour essayer
quelque chose
faut que j'essaye de toute façon
ah oui la sacrifié directement
ok j'avais vu mais je pensais pas que
c'était possible de faire ça
ok bon terminal ado il y a comme une
petite embrouille comment on gère ça
sauf avec quelques secondes à la pendule
il
punaise c'est quoi ce embrouille
la grosse embrouille à la fin c'était
énorme
avec cette cette belle nulle voyez ça
enchaîne en direct ça enchaîne direct ah
oui c'est chaud
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire et vous
voyez ça enchaîne direct avec une
attaque figatello party italienne mais
la partie italienne des gros bourrins et
puis là les joueurs jouent vite hein
normalement c'est ce qu'on dit c'est ce
qu'on dit il faut prouver il y a des
grosses compensations maintenant pour
les Noirs même si
alors oui oui le crush you c'est
vraiment marrant parce que il dit j'ai
jamais vu Fabi sourire comme ça bah
ouais voilà l'arnaque était belle on a
pas eu le temps de la remontrer mais
franchement c'était un vol de haut vol
souffle non c'est franchement c'était
pas super dur
il a trouvé une belle carotte et puis
ils avaient quelques secondes à la
pendule donc c'est énorme
donc oui il faut que je la garde G3 il y
a du jeu maintenant donc une qualité
d'avance pour pour aryoun mais Fabiano
va lui mettre tous les coups du tennis
et cavaliers des quatre c'est déjà hyper
chaud ce coup-là
aux Cavalia 3 on a même
quand on vous montre que
que sortir des pièces sur les côtés sur
la dame trop vite tout ça ouais c'est
vraiment un petit peu une exception aux
échecs on voit souvent c'était cette
Italienne
[Musique]
et mais elle peut être joue aussi chez
les joueurs professionnels
à condition d'avoir une idée quand même
parce que
il y a le combat d'Ariane qui a pris le
matos pour gagner la finale et Fabiano
qui lui dit bah vas-y je te file le
marathon mais je vais te tuer en moins
de vin coup quoi c'est un peu ça le
combat quoi
et on a l'impression que Fabiano il
vient de jouer fou des 6 c'est hyper
embêtant
mes pièces sont hyperactives
contre pointes d'Ariane cavaliers
et il joue une vitesse les deux
d'ailleurs ils vont être chaud pour le
Bullet tout à l'heure ouais non ça joue
en tout cas c'est ils sont préparés hein
ils sont 15e
ton Messenger ce serait cool merci
c'est Nathan de cheesecom et du coup
j'avais une question pour lui technique
d'accord par contre il est actif sur le
chat c'est cool mais par contre
la qualité des parties
mais c'est vrai que
si on fait cavaler le fou G4 et abandon
direct ouh là là incroyable
c'est pas fait Fabiano alors que c'était
assez prometteur mais cavaliers 4
faisait mal
mais de là abandonné direct c'était
quand même étonnant
pas mal quand même
donc du coup il lui a fait mal ça fait
quand même à Fabiano alors que ça joue à
fond la caisse quand même
parce qu'on saigne plus ça a quand même
du temps mais les mecs qui jouent comme
ambulette ils gardent pas trop de temps
on voit que dès que c'est le dès que
c'est la fin de partie ça peut être très
chaud avec la belle arnaque tout à
l'heure de de Fabiano qui est assez
réussie à trouver une énorme ressource
il a choisi peut-être le mode un peu
plus béton cette fois t'as vu sauf
peut-être qu'on va peut-être qu'on va
arrêter les bêtises maintenant dans les
grandes complications on va faire
peut-être du jeu positionnel parce que
sinon il va se faire embrouiller tout le
temps
avec les Blancs c'est plus facile de
choisir d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
parlons un petit peu parlons un petit
peu Paris
c'est que l'arbitre Fatou modo est sur
le chat
que propose tout tu
c'est pas mal le que propose tout mais
il faut que je note moi aussi la
dernière fois j'ai pas noté du coup tu
vois on était en BT
alors du coup normalement c'est 1 1 5
par phase non c'est bien ou pas
comment ça
bah tu sais il y a les faces 5 + 5 3 + 1
1 + 1 et match global quelque chose
comme ça je crois que c'est un truc du
genre mais bon je sais pas comme ça ce
qu'on veut
c'est toi qui dit alors parce que tu es
meilleur que moi pour ça j'ai moi j'ai
sorti mon crayon cette fois ok
bah écoute on peut bah déjà il y a je
pense qu'on peut mettre un petit truc
sur le score final toi tu veux vraiment
prendre un gazer
tu imagines qu'est-ce que je veux dire
au prochain top
voilà
mais
la première partie c'est pas bon signe
ouais bon après c'est l'entrée un petit
peu en matière c'est ça
[Musique]
il est quand même chaud normalement il
peut aussi en plus
[Musique]
on peut dire que le vainqueur de chaque
segment
jeu et tu mets un petit un petit bonus
pour pour
le vainqueur quoi pour le match quoi
donc on fait quoi pour le 5 + 1 par
exemple on fait 1 on fait 2 on fait ce
que tu veux faire
OK et on fait 4 sur le résultat final ça
peut faire du coup 10 en tout voilà j'ai
proposé un 5 et toi tu as pensé que tu
as des modéré et non non pas du tout
c'est avec plaisir c'est marrant bah du
coup
les dettes sur le stream de stuff voilà
il faut que je passe mais là honnêtement
la position la position d'irégasis
j'aime pas trop parce que il a ses pions
tout à fait déliés j'ai l'impression que
ça va être plutôt sympa à jouer un petit
carré G4 là au pire on fait fou prendre
des cinq à aller au 3 et dame C3
sont faibles donc sur case noir c'est
assez ouvert et bon après attention
depuis un 4 il gagne bien avancé si on
perdait deux il peut y avoir des petits
problèmes le pion qui avance tout ça
c'est pas c'est pas simple donc voilà
bah écoute moi je vais parier
de partout sur un carnaval
je vais pas m'amuser à me gourer sur le
seul truc tu sais on essaye de c'est un
peu contre cœur tu vois
désolé alors non du coup
alors du coup j'ai pas regardé mais
mercredi prochain on revient avec
stouffe pour commenter on a quel match
déjà il faut que je faut que je mette
dedans vous savez on peut vous citer les
matchs avec avec stouf qu'il y aura
voilà bon je les ai je les avais devant
les yeux mais en tout cas donc là on
attaque les huitièmes donc on aura
Nakamura par Aviane en drekin à rognan
digly Rennes contre grischhook
contre carwana il y aura aussi Wesley
Sow contre abdosa torov nordi Beck noire
parce que j'arrive pas du tout à le dire
faut pas que mvl contre nepaux c'est
plus facile comme ça donc du coup
dimanche on aura Ding du coup qui va
jouer contre
qui sera commenté par Kevin Bordy sur la
chaîne test et puis on aura lundi Netto
mvl commenter aussi par Kevin Bordy et
on reviendra nous mercredi 30 avec un
petit aronial André Kim
et puis du coup et du coup je te
laisserai choisir stouf je laisserai
choisir c'est normal parce que tu me
fais beaucoup de politesse et du coup à
chaque fois j'arrive à te griller la
politesse c'est moche donc je te laisse
le choix bah ça va être honnêtement à
rognan à rognan
c'est quand même une préférence
sera plus fort mais là je pense que
c'est le Paris à prendre parce que sur
le papier mais en fait au final pas tant
que ça je pense
j'ai tourné la tête il s'est pris il a
réussi à faire ses quatre facilement à
rien pour essayer de
d'embrouiller un petit peu
maintenant c'est des chances j'ai
l'impression hein
qui est très actif
et j'aime beaucoup comment ils ont
salut on est
et j'ai du mal à rencontrer la casse ces
quatre
et le principe à comprendre c'est qu'au
niveau de la structure on souffrait avec
avec les Noirs donc il est en train
d'échanger les faiblesses contre des
forces blanches en tout cas la structure
va devenir bizarre des deux côtés
bon je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on joue
dans B5 peut-être d'un bout j'ai
peut-être des quatre peut-être qui veut
des 4 ouais
aussi peut-être faire dame B6
effectivement
on est alors peut-être que si
étant le chat malheureusement nous on
n'a pas accès à au titre c'est comme je
ne peux pas toucher
qui l'a mis en place ou pas
merci pour ta remarque on a aidé donc je
vais quand même leur écrire on s'est
dédouané direct et maintenant j'ai pas
accès au titre je peux pas bah c'est
clair c'est clair ça peut pas venir de
nous une faute comme ça à tout
ça a été joué comme ça sur D4 bon on
peut tout prendre et maintenant bah on
est juste mieux sans doute avec les
Noirs ce qui était pas le cas tout à
l'heure dans BK
[Musique]
sans doute allez on pourrait
pronostiquer une égalité à la fin
[Musique]
suite tour des trois peut-être
pour garder le pressing il y aurait trop
B4 madame des 6 c'est beaucoup mieux
c'est beaucoup plus malin je pense
à ce moment-là c'est déjà c'est déjà une
petite avance confortable
il va aller manger à 4
attention que là actuellement s'il
mangeait à 4 et ben il parvient une
pièce avec tout reprendre il y aurait
dame il y aurait tourner à la fin car
elle est D1 d’apprender un d'un point à
quatre ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas grand
chose quand même pour l'instant non
en l'air attention je B2 j'ai quand même
deux pions qui peuvent avancer pour des
trois carrés
[Musique]
tactiquement il est là
il y a pas de sauvetage ici
intermédiaire et après je pourrais
manger ici
500 B2
ans quand même moi je pense ça dépend où
est mon roi mais je pourrais faire
tourner un et amener mon roi
en tout cas apparemment ça va vite
ça va vite et c'est pas clair je vérifie
la finale tu as pas le choix je pense
essayer de regarder fouder cette un peu
par hasard mais ah d'accord ok bon il a
un problème plus il peut jouer pour pour
être bien pénible quand même ouais un
petit peu
je pense qu'il va gagner un peu de temps
non
mais bon
plus correct je pense qu'il va la jouer
qui aimerait gazer
le bras comme ça
il y avait un chat qui allait sauter
sa saveur cette pause
il a quand même il s'est fait bien
dominé quand même une fois que ça c'est
inquiétant statiquement on sent que
kerwana c'était la grande classe
stratégique dans le début mais
il va essayer de le bloquer avec des
ouvertures vraiment un peu triste car
wanna et Charles
chaque fois
mais ça promet quand même souffle parce
que quand les cadences vont se réduire
il va une vitesse
à rioun
franchement il pourrait bien nous fait
des lysés
tu sais avec Mia il s'amusait à faire
des 10 secondes chacun tu sais
[Musique]
ils font souvent ça
pour se détendre le soir tu vois après
les parties lentes
donc du coup
ce genre de cadence c'est vraiment très
dur
en tout cas je suis pas mécontent pour
l'instant de mon pari et tout
je pleurais je pleurais mercredi
prochain parce que si j'avais dû choisir
je vais évidemment choisir un rognan
mais écoute c'est comme ça c'est normal
de tourner un petit peu mais
j'aurais préféré avoir un match un peu
plus serré sur le papier après
en fait tous les matchs sont
franchement
alors que Robin side il dit c'est normal
la cam de kerwana dans score de regga
Easy et vice-versa
malheureusement malheureusement moi je
[Musique]
attends non mais c'est bon Fatou elle a
répondu OUI et du coup Robinson trouve
ça aussi normal il faut juste
la réponse et puis après c'est nickel ça
se voit pas
ça se voit pas je trouve c'est moi
j'avais pas vu tu vois j'avais pas vu
exactement on a ls ça force à suivre le
match au moins je suis complètement
d'accord avec toi
voilà il y a la petite feinte la petite
fin de plusieurs scènes en fait il
faudrait que je te rappelle moi-même
très beau beaucoup faire quand même
souffle du coup on est dans cette
pétrole et
franchement
sauf que la position obtenue par par
carwana est vraiment assez confortable
paire de fou avec un fou de casse
blanche vraiment intéressant
pourquoi pas ici cahier des trois
peut-être avec C4
la bien négocié le câble de l'ouverture
visiblement
et c'est vrai que maintenant la petite
transition speech
est-ce qu'on pourrait même faire un truc
de folie stouf et tourner l'échiquier
est-ce qu'on est-ce que tu as la main
là-dessus tu voudrais que je prenne
[Musique]
du bon côté de son échiquier
je peux mettre le côté blanc
et comme ça c'est la folie totale
il surveille un Robin side il laisse
rien passer sous fin tu le connais
il laisse les clés mais il vérifie quand
même
donc en tout cas
on a un pion passé éléphant pour ceux
qui ne savent pas ce que c'est un pion
passé éléphant bah vous l'avez en
Détroit et ben c'est un pion qui casse
bien les pieds franchement alors
comme ça un pion passé qui est très très
éloigné il est pas soutenu donc il va
falloir essayer de l'attraper avec
avec les Blancs
mais ça paraît pas si facile que ça
bah c'est ça
va réussir à le pêcher ce pion
c'est chaud quand même parce que par
exemple surtout des deux il y a des
quatre le cavalier noir pourrait revenir
dans la bataille
ça va prendre du temps d'aller chercher
et pendant ce temps là l'adversaire va
s'activer
sur ton tour des deux cavaliers il y
avait pour l'instant ton Pione 5 en
l'air donc regarde tu vois Fabiano il
amène ses pièces grâce à l'avantage
d'espace et franchement
c'est important aussi les cases blanches
ici et le pion est sur casse blanche du
coup il le tient quand même beaucoup
mieux c'est ça que s'il était sur 15
noirs comme nous disent tous et du coup
on manque d'espace quand même un spion
de trois il nous contraint beaucoup et
du coup A5
même pas moi j'aurais misé la maison sur
le genre indien mais comme c'est un
joueur qui qui fait partie de l'équipe
de Top 12 de Kevin Kevin a voulu parier
sur lui un peu tu vois et
[Musique]
bon bah dommage bah du coup je respecte
et bon ok c'est quand même pas mal de
parler sur carbonara quand même mais
évidemment j'aurais pu j'aurais parié
sur les régatilles
d'ailleurs un petit taille anecdote si
on est vraiment émerveillé par le jeu de
nos trois indiens aux échecs par contre
il était émerveillé du niveau de foot
que l'on avait par rapport à leur propre
niveau je peux vous dire que c'est ces
joueurs indiens vont mieux les les
prendre au foot qu'aux échecs ils
étaient quand même bien plus modeste
vous auriez vu la pernale Sarine et
Arion et regga easy en même temps
au milieu de terrain je peux vous dire
que il y avait il y avait des trous
d'air c'est pas c'est pas comme tes
Pogba je peux vous dire et ils étaient
bien conscients d'ailleurs de leur
niveau par contre un des grands maîtres
se débrouillait pas mal en claquettes je
l'avais dit à stouf c'est leoning
mandanka qui a un très joli niveau au
foot et c'est assez rare et Niall ouais
c'est modeste voilà alors moi c'est bien
moi que c'est bien moins fort
moi au foot je suis quand même pas très
très fort non plus
je pense que tu te débrouilles un peu
mieux que surtout au NiAl NiAl c'était
quand même il a pas de il aime bien ça
il aime bien ça
il aime bien il aime bien ça d'ailleurs
ouais
mais il a mis ça
ça va
j'avais une fois avec Sami mais c'était
il y a vraiment très longtemps et je
m'étais pas trop mal débrouillé et puis
après on avait rejoué une autre fois en
Espagne et
et c'était catastrophique le terrain il
était comme tu vois le terrain il
faisait 3 km et en fait quand tu arrives
au bout du terrain bah juste paraître
et maintenant il y a l'âge qui avance tu
vois tout du coup cette prise en plus
dur mine de rien il faut une grotte
encore jeune à l'époque ok ok
du coup du coup ça serait pire
aujourd'hui c'est ça que je veux te dire
souffre pour démo la réaliser total
en plus je me suis arrêté les chaussures
exprès pour jouer au foot à l'après-midi
et en une heure mais je suis sur son
cassées
j'ai appris le truc à 8 euros tu sais
c'était les pires chaussures j'ai fini
en avec les chaussures sans la semelle
c'était beau
et
toujours avec son petit pion en Détroit
là
j'aime beaucoup les Noirs mais du coup
maintenant je suis obligé de de soutenir
un Caravana même si tu sais que
secrètement je suis pour iriasi
terrible
c'est comme ça
et Fabiano il est en train de chercher
comment passer dans cette position parce
que bon on n'a pas trouvé pour l'instant
pas si facile
c'est dur dur dur
tant qu'il tourne autour de la bestiole
on est quand même bien fixé ici
vraiment pas évident de passer
en même temps les blancs sont en
soumission
donc on va bien voir
on a tourbé un je pense que rien ne sait
pas trop quoi faire et regarder ce joli
cavalier à 7 position un peu bloqué
voilà position à manœuvre ou la BAM E6
alors j'ai envie de dire Kevin
pour en fait ouvrir
ces pièces en fait il ouvre le fou il a
une casse pour cavalier en E5 et la
position était quand même bien bloquée
sur case noire et il a envie du coup de
respirer quoi
un peu plus logique
en pratique c'est pas un mauvais coup je
pense au contraire au contraire mais
c'est jouer hyper vite c'est ça qui est
qui est fou d'ailleurs et maintenant on
imagine des cavaliers E5 tours 1 et
d'essai d'embrouiller
il a joué tout droit d'abord ça m'étonne
un peu je crois que c'est ça Robinson
d'ailleurs il avait été incroyable
ambulette alors que tout le monde
attendait en disant que oui en Bullet il
a une fois éclater il avait été
monstrueux Caravana ambulette
donc pas cette estimé au final c'est
quand même très très bon genre d'échec
et
de toute façon il est à plus de 3000 sur
chatcom on sait ce que ça veut dire
beaucoup oui non c'est ça complètement
c'est juste qu'il est extrêmement doué
et cela quelque soit la cadence
mais en face il a forte à faire mais là
il domine quand même à une pour la
première fois puisque Fabien il s'en
sort pas mal pour l'instant parce qu'il
a eu trois trois défaites potentiels et
ça c'est fini en deux une défaite et si
venez à gagner ici bah c'est totalement
lancé
il fait mal là en plus à chaque coup
mais avec la vingtaine de secondes à
chaque joueur à chaque fois ça peut
damadofu C3
très très vite et
on voit que les pièces bougent aussi
donc là je sais pas peut-être
roi qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire contre
ces joueurs là pour gagner ça donne
envie ouais j'aime bien
on a pas le temps de voir tant que ça
vous voyez là c'est c'est déjà hyper
speed
et faire des deux peut-être
il joue plus vite quand même je trouve
et regaizi dans ce qu'on voit là il est
en train de retourner il a retourné
mais ça va jouer au clic maintenant
garde les pièces sur l'échiquier
de Bullet et je pense que je pense que
tu avais raison
ça joue à fond la caisse normal
[Musique]
d'un F4 on a plus le temps il a bouffé
le piment
à sa joie à la main ça peut déconner à
n'importe quel moment
c'est bien ce qui fait que c'est d'une
propre hôtel
ça va faire suer
ça peut faire nul maintenant alors que
c'était foutu
incroyable
[Musique]
impressionnant rien à dire c'est pas
facile à commenter tellement ça joue
bien à la fin c'était vraiment très très
chaud
bon première fois où à Rio ne se
retrouve en difficulté et il a tenu le
choc
c'est bon
donc du coup
petite variante avec G4 sur ce c'est une
pire Tiger
du coup jouer par Arion pour gagner avec
les Noirs c'est un super choix bon mon
cœur et puis pour embrouiller en fait
index qui est le favori sur ce format
bon ça reste toujours la même favorite
tu dirais c'est comme une bonne question
qu'on a là de Alex stouf qui est tout
favori stuff
je pense c'est le meilleur quoi et
Carlson
devrait être pas une malle aussi dans ce
genre de format d'ailleurs j'ai regardé
un petit peu il y a eu des pas mal de de
comme je t'ai dit
il est stats par rapport au match je les
ai ici je peux te les lire si tu veux
alors Alex juste pour te répondre il y a
stouf qui avait les stats du match pour
aujourd'hui les stades donnés 70 %
presque à Fabiano carwana or moi j'étais
assez content de parier sur aryoun et si
tout avait dû choisir il aurait fait
demain mais il m'a laissé il m'a laissé
gentiment mon partenaire de club comme
comme favori
mais en tout cas les stats étaient pour
carwana après franchement sur un match
ça veut tout et rien dire à Rio il est
plus jeune c'est une cadence hyper speed
je pense qu'il avait un petit Edge moi
pour pour être tout à fait franc alors
juste je vais vous lire un petit peu les
prédictions de ces matchs alors on en a
Nakamura contre par Aviane
par avion je sais pas comment tu le
prononces
et du coup donc les prédictions donc je
crois que c'est un programme qui qui
nous fait ça et il donne 98% sur
Nakamura
en même temps c'est pas ouais
bon c'est énorme mais je pense il y a
plein de parties si vous voulez donc il
y a moins de variance que s'il y en
avait trois quoi
André Keane donc aronia il est favori à
55 % car 55 % seulement soufflent je
pensais avoir fait une fleur tu vois
dans ce genre de format je me disais que
bon ça allait peut-être plus dur mais
bon
de voir que favoris à
79%. ça c'est ça m'étonne
c'est quand même beaucoup tu vois
incroyable
[Musique]
c'est pas un débile quand même 20 %
c'est beaucoup je trouve après
incroyable aussi on voit que Sarine est
porté favoris contre guéri à 54% c'est
pas mal aussi ouais mais ça me choque
moins parce que Sarine c'est vraiment
saccadant s'il va quand je les ai vu à
carioune ils font ils en font beaucoup
hein
je vais revenir après bon 45 97% contre
Google ça m'a l'air OK
[Musique]
ce que je suis pas d'accord
ça c'est bizarre
aussi c'est quand même beaucoup en 80 tu
vois bon
et après je vois que
[Musique]
ne pas mener à Hatchi à 78% contre mdr
ce qui est aussi incroyable
tous les deux entre mvl et dépôt
Wesley Sow moi j'aurais plutôt dit en
ça donne carvana moi je l'aurais mis pas
favori contre
au niveau des parties d'ailleurs c'est
en train de se vérifier
et là il est enfin 70-30 ça paraît quand
même peu et tu vois pour moi irrigazie
et sa ring ça se voit un petit peu et
ils disent que ça rime il est 54% sur
Giri
tu vois alors que il y a 30% contre 70
sur sur faberland après c'est bizarre
c'est en fait c'est un peu chelou mais
ok bon écoute
je sais pas comment ils font leur leur
pronostics leurs trucs en tout cas
ça va bien salut
mais on avait l'impression ici que
comment dirais-je Fabiano à l'être en
difficulté et finalement il a réussi
avec A5 à trouver des ressources et pas
être trop fixé il va quand même souffrir
un petit peu ouais parce que tu as le
mauvais fou contre le cavalier et du
coup normalement les noirs sont pas mal
ouais il y aurait eu à 5 à 4 en plus
bloqué ça aurait été génial et là on va
pouvoir exercer un petit pressing
ce qui peut arriver aussi avec le fou le
pion C2 qui peut aussi être sous
pression tout le temps
[Musique]
essayer de de peut-être même jouer un
jour dans le 5 essayer de jouer actif et
d'avoir le maximum de
mais en fait à chaque coup de pion vous
voyez que ça donne des cases
[Musique]
je pense qu'il peut pas perdre et qu'il
joue vraiment pour
pour
gagner c'est moi ou entend moins un
stouf moins fort que Kevin
très bien ce souffle mais dans le stream
ça peut être un peu différent
mon micro il est à côté de moi
j'ai tout normal donc ça ne doit pas
être normal
et du coup alors comment on fait dans
cette position Roger 7 tout calme
moi j'ai pas trop envie de jouer F5
pourtant parce que j'ai peur de donner
les cases je trouve ça me dérange F5 et
17 comme tu le disais ça va faire encore
une case pour le cavalier
maintenant en fait c'est difficile de
trouver des idées pour les blancs donc
Wave 2 Rois 3 ça serait simple voilà si
c'est un peu borderline mais entre roi
et trois rois et 4 et voir ce qui se
passe et ce qui est bien c'est que le
kb6 c'est un peu obligé de rester là
pour l'instant à cause des fous C4 donc
ça devient
exactement tu peux pas vraiment
contrôler mon foie de ton cavalier et
bon il y a un pressing noir mais pas
simple de vraiment passer honnêtement
comment on continue c'est pas simple on
aimerait bien mettre une pression sur le
pion C2 mais c'est très difficile d'y
arriver
dès qu'on quitte avec une tour la
colonne à l'adversaire simé ah voilà des
cinq bon voilà une prise de risque
directe de
alors du coup bon si on prend le
cavalier va rentrer il y a des cases pas
mal après chaque échange favorise les
blancs mais
5 et 6 terribles parce que maintenant le
fou il aura plus la case
et du coup
il veut sûrement faire ça il faut
prendre et pousser cinq moi je pense
qu'il veut ouvrir sa position avec son
fou et donc voir un petit peu dessin que
c'est quand une prise de risque ce qu'il
a fait pas comment jouer la position la
règle d'or c'est pas si facile
tour D8 peut-être
tu veux faire quoi en fait
le peut-être c'est ça qui est bon
en fait le jour où tu fais des quatre et
que tu qu'avec ça que j'ai fout ces
quatre enfin je vais prendre et faire un
truc
c'est pas si simple non c'est pas simple
de tout en tout cas il joue tous les
deux pour le gain pour l'instant ça joue
des claques
c'est normalement c'est pas c'est pas
une assurance des excuses les mecs ils
ont des excuses
un petit peu ce genre de séquence avec
le cavalier qui vient E5 est-ce qu'on
peut passer fousser 4 très vite et fut
des cinq
contrôleur
5 j'attaquerai en fait parce que protégé
après
tout le temps ouais c'est limite là ça
va être très limite maintenant avec 50
secondes dans la pendule en plus
il y a plus de 6 malins à FC c'était
bien joué en fait
d'un coup j'aime bien les blancs tu sais
quoi c'est pas faux j'ai l'impression
qu'il s'est fait un peu arnaquer parce
que fout de sacs doit rester là parce
que le pion F7 fait trop faible et après
peut-être échanger une tour voir si je
peux aller manger une pion des 4 aussi
alors après je peux mettre une pression
sur le pion C2 du coup tu auras deux
peut-être voilà 3 2 c'est le bordel
maintenant voilà prise prise et il y a
pas de il y a pas de de
ces trois on préfère quand même un petit
peu les Noirs j'ai l'impression ici
mais après ce que je peux jouer il y a
une pression là dessus mais si j'arrive
en battre le pion BE4
attends il y a tout reprend B3 ou pas de
position voilà c'était pas très bien
joué en fait
du coup c'était une bonne gaffe surtout
mais ils ont pas tant les mecs
ça paraissait bon et en fait c'est une
bonne gaffe mais bon ça reste toujours
compliqué
toujours sous pression
parce que la tour était mal placée
embêtant
le roi F4 encore une fois
toutes les parties
l'histoire du qui va arriver avec H4
quand G4 et peut-être tenir on avait pas
besoin de pouvoir mettre un dispositif
en place trois chiffres et 5
ça va pas être facile quand même non
c'est pas simple parce que je peux pas
pousser F5 jamais le faire là on peut
faire le grand tour peut-être avec le
roi et bien le prix de 4 voilà c'est
fini là c'est terminé quand tu perds 4
d'ailleurs là ça va être facilement
gagner ouais
je pense
oui bah là il a fait le grand tour il va
pousser son Pione jusqu'au bout du monde
prime F3 maintenant
comment tu finis
et tomber
encore et là ça commence
la pub les joueurs partent en pause
nous on va partir aussi en pause les
gars donc on se revoit cette pub là et
le chrono tourne toujours pendant la pub
sauf
[Musique]
malheureusement
mais du coup on revient après la pause
environ en 5 minutes les gars donc
restez connectés je vous dis à tout de
suite je voulais je vous passe une
petite une petite page de pot de pub et
à tout de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
et nous sommes revenus avec hello à tous
qui a disparu et qui a réapparu voilà et
la caméra qui m'a encore changé
et les joueurs sont sont prêts et ça
envoie direct
une chance sur deux la caméra elle
change c'est un truc de fou carwana noir
ouais exactement c'est un truc de fou
et du coup une quatre cavaliers H3
modeste
[Musique]
de Cabana une fois sur deux ça change
c'est insupportable
[Musique]
donc vas-y je te laisse on est reparti
direct donc 4 cavaliers H3 prise du
centre en fait
erghisy a joué quelque chose d'assez
d'assez modeste et directement car Wana
il prend tout le centre c'est du grand
classique et il y va ici une souligne
finalement pas trop d'ambition dans les
ouvertures par contre grosse ambition
derrière les ouvertures donc ça ça va
envoyer et je disais à ce tout faut là
pendant la pause que Ben Fabiano c'était
dur pour lui la pose pouvait lui faire
du bien parce que sinon à mon avis ça
pouvait complètement déconner il y
aurait encore deux parties derrière dans
la foulée de ce qui s'était pris c'est
ça commençait à être dur
rappelons que Fabiano il y a toujours
pas gagné une partie donc ça commence ça
commence à être dur 3 nuls de défaite
si ça commence à s'enchaîner dans cette
cadence où je pense qu'il est peut-être
le plus fort normalement en 5 + 1 en 3 +
1 et 1 + 1 ça va être dur pourtant il y
a très très beaux réflexes Fabienne à
carwana c'est un des meilleurs joueurs
de tous les temps par contre c'est une
cadence tellement spécifique et ça reste
du jeu sur internet que c'est vraiment
pas vraiment pas évident ouais c'est
clair donc par de fou pour les Noirs
quand même avec deux pions isolés
mais intéressantes et ouais dans ces
dans ce schéma là en fait dès que tu
commences à te prendre bulle sur bulle
ça peut devenir très très très compliqué
donc là c'est important que qu'avant
score est réussi ça ne passe faire
marcher dessus
d'entrée de match donc là pour l'instant
on est à deux points d'écart avec Arjun
qui a pris la tête
et du coup ben je pense que
je pense que
Kawana à hacker de se refaire cette
partie
et de revenir au score
c'est pas grand chose mais ça peut
devenir inquiétant et puis là
à voir la petite pression qui va bien
sur le pion c'est 52
c'est vraiment pénible son dernier coup
qui a validé B3 avec des fous 3
et on va mettre des pièces adverse en
soumission donc ça y est Fabiano il
envoie il envoie les pions mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu contre X
peut-être E4
parce que sinon je voulais bien faire
des faux trois dames et 6 peut-être
quelque chose comme ça
faut pas se faire enfermer la dame donc
il est parti parfois B2 puisque
maintenant sur F5 est faible long terme
et dès que l'option E5 avant ça laisse
toute la diagonale au four il a une
adaptation sauf hyper rapide dans toutes
les situations pour le placement des
pièces
qui me choque c'est pas la qualité des
coûts c'est la qualité des coups plus le
timing quoi il joue très vite il a un
super instinct
il y a peut-être une parade mais ça va
être ça va être déjà dur cette histoire
parce que maintenant il s'aperçoit je
pense et c'était pas totalement maîtrisé
peut-être à moins que
donc faut prendre 5 là il y a des faux
français quand évidemment dans ce genre
de config je pense qu'il veut se venger
là-dessus peut-être avec friperon ici
qui peut être français
faut prendre cinq faux français 4 et
peut-être F4 faudrait garder mais les
cases blanches s'ouvre donc voilà il
fait le pressing c'est normal
ici il y a une pression de domination
sur le long terme mais il va pas mettre
en place les embrouilles par contre
Fabiano il doit mettre quelque chose au
centre il doit faire quelque chose mais
il faut être concret parce que si tu
fais rien en fait tu vas perdre ses 5
et position elle est très difficile
pourtant en fait si tu fais rien c'est
ça
en tout cas vous voyez que are Yuni
prend l'initiative tout le temps et il
casse les pieds de Fabiano et il faut
que Fabiano trouve quelque chose dans
cette position
pas comment avancer là peut-être qu'on
peut déjà croquer ces cinq attention il
veut revenir en C6 pour mettre pression
sur G2
faut prendre ça 5 pouces et 6 d'un F1 ce
qu'on a mieux que ça
bon
ça faisait peur je préférais dame enfin
un peu plus stable peut-être pas tout vu
évidemment mais c'est le genre de coup
qui faisait peur donc justement il avait
anticipé sans doute voilà F prend ef-ed4
grosse grosse impression pour
très très vite
mais il y a des cinq soufre qui qui va
altérer la puissance du fossé 6
mais j'aurais eu trop peur si tu veux
tout pour jouer un truc comme ça quoi
mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
et c'est dans laquelle bon ben je prends
je prends
la chance
toi qui va le prendre en F2 mais ah mais
il va peut-être maintenant prendre un
dame tout reprendre
pour la qualité ouais c'est ça
[Musique]
mais ok roi je sens c'est quand même un
coup
ils sont belles les parties pour en tout
cas on voit que carwana a alors qu'il
est mené quand même de deux points
ben il a dû répondre il a réussi à
ouvrir la position
à 5 encore un trou un coup où il essaie
de
balancer parce que le pion en l'air le
temps
sur la colonne B ouvrir un petit peu
tout ça virer le cavalier à 4 a été joué
ce pion peut être sur le long terme
il doit montrer la Fabiano que
les tours bah jouent sur les colonnes
donc il doit ouvrir les colonnes d'où
son coin 5 il doit faire quelque chose
parce que sur le long terme se
positionne est difficile donc tout re 5
bons coups pour doubler sur la E par
exemple ou transférer la tour sur la 5e
rangée
ou des cartes gagne la case C5 pour le
cavalier
quand même pour la tour donc peut-être
pas de suite mais tu vois ton F5 plutôt
F8 il faut être très instinctif dans ces
positions là c'est pas c'est pas évident
c'est pour les deux joueurs c'est chaud
en pratique je pense que les Blancs
parce que c'est plus facile
j'avoue que
sa présence
ça peut basculer d'un moment à un autre
j'ai pas d'âme des siège avec peut-être
c'est très épais
grosse perte d'argent oui et non encore
une fois
Kevin et moi d'accord pour pour dire que
argent n'était clairement pas
pour moi il était favori en fait sur le
papier franchement pour moi les favoris
dans toute cette année là
en blitz en Bullet sur tous les sites
c'est juste une grosse machine en tout
cas il a été bouffée à 5 et là j'avais
peur parce que les pièces noires sont
braquées il y a 4 pièces noires braquer
sur le roi blanc et s'en fiche il va
croquer à 5 en fait là il te dit
concrètement ce qui se passe
je suis rien moi je ramène mon cavalier
je pousse le pion
maintenant elle lui dit bon bah ouais
Fabiano lui placer pièces ça fait hyper
peur quoi
un fou prend H3 celui de G3 ou un truc
comme ça
c'est hyper bizarre ce qu'il a fait je
trouve ça paraît vraiment très très
optimiste
plus donc d'habitude lui qui est si
rapide
avec le cavalier en plus il est mal
placé dans tous les variantes
l'idée de dame G3 de fou prend H3 vous
voyez tout le monde qui arrive on a un
peu annoncé et argent qui est très mal
au temps cette partie
pour une fois
va être forcé je pense
parce que
pour mettre une carotte un cavalier
et
un truc en fait je sais pas
ouais c'est possible
c'est compliqué cette histoire et car
voilà qui se revient encore mal au temps
[Musique]
il a réussi à s'en sortir j'ai
l'impression que ça a glissé entre les
mains de carwana
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont forts niveau
défense attaque chaque soir ça c'est
monstrueux
ils savent bien jouer les positions
difficiles et encore à Rio il prend les
il prend les pions ils s'en fout là
maintenant il est vraiment mieux là
c'est dur pour agenote les tours sont
enfermés maintenant
et puis il est vraiment très mal au
temps
est vraiment dur tu auras 5 c'est
possible ou pas
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
maintenant c'est la bonne cagoule
celle-là parce que franchement il avait
fait sa plus jolie partie je pense qu'à
Juana il aurait
pu dû gagner et là
mentalement ça va être hyper raidas
donc la trois points de retard
en 5 + 1 qui était censé être la la
cadence ou Carana a été peut-être le
plus fort et
je pense que je pense clairement que les
prédictions étaient mauvaises moi
j'étais sûr que que
ça se passe bien
il faut que ça continue comme ça Fabi
surtout changer rien c'est très très
bien ce que tu nous fais non mais bon là
c'est des belles parties en plus
malheureusement
il a été hyper solide un moment je
pensais qu'à Rio n'était foutu et il a
réussi à tenir ok je pense qu'à Juan a
peut-être raté quelque chose mais
c'était pas non plus
en défense ils sont tellement fort ça
fait deux fois quand même que ARJO n'est
et limite perdant et deux fois qu'il
arrive à ne pas perdre quoi bon il a
fait un million c'est parti là
et par contre quand Caravana est mal ben
il lui colle quoi
on est capable mais là le problème c'est
que il y a un petit coup au moral à la
même dans ce genre d'exercice
trois bulles trois nuls en six parties
pour un mec de talent là c'est pas tous
les jours il donne ces deux pour
l'activité ouais c'est un classique mais
qu'est-ce que tu penses de d'impenser le
tournage 3
plus naturel sauf comme ça il y a des
petites menaces de cahier prend un 5 en
prime
F4 de tout à l'heure
et il y a un peu moins d'activités pour
pour les blancs il y en a quand même
ouvertes et la tour très souvent elle va
sortir par là des fois on peut en faire
petit rock qui
normales F3 qui sont
ça existe
petit bidet qui
nous défendait qu'à Rouana et oui c'est
terrible je suis assez d'accord avec les
30 secondes en plus qu'il avait au
départ et du coup à Rio n'a joué cette
finale et il a préféré changer les dames
pour contrer toutes velléité sur le roi
et jouer cette petite finale qui me
paraissait pas si bonne pour les noirs
que les pièces noires sont longs à la
tourage fuite cavalier G8 touffe moi je
dirais avantage blanc ici
la tour me paraît trop loin du jeu
forcer
tour des trois tours va être joué quasi
sûr
et tu as le fou
ouais on a le fou des deux quand même
sur le long terme les pions oui
je commence après
je voulais jouer avec ces quatre je peux
pas pour l'instant avec cavalier B3 qui
traîne j'ai toujours des 6 je sais pas
sur
c'est bien quelque chose comme ça
c'est pas si facile
[Musique]
maintenant roi E7 et puis en fait ça va
la tour on va aller au centre
on n'est pas moins bien évidemment avec
les blancs mais sans doute c'est plus
égal qu'il n'y paraîtrait au départ
ouais on a l'impression que les blancs
avec un bel avantage de développement
mais au final ça c'est résorbé il a un
super sens de l'initiative quoi ouais
c'est ouf
il est toujours très actif ça je te l'ai
dit depuis le début
les joueurs indiens en règle générale de
toute façon enfin je voyais dans le il y
a eu un séminaire
d'entraîneur animés par Romulus labaka
canechec que tu connais hyper bien il y
avait invité ramèche et ce qu'il en
sortait j'étais regarder le compte rendu
et ramasse je disais qu'il fallait
apprendre très tôt l'activité aux jeunes
la prise d'initiative et que c'était
vraiment valorisée dans au sein de son
école quoi donc en fait toute façon pour
gagner aux échecs il faut mettre la
pression sur les joueurs si vous mettez
la pression contre un bon joueur le
joueur devient moins bon c'est le seul
moyen de toute façon
il faut sortir les jours de leur zone de
confort
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il a vu sur 3 à 4
qui arrive chez karena donc
on peut bouffer à 4 donc on pouvait pas
quelque chose mais j'ai pas vu j'ai pas
vu
peut-être sauf
une pression
là j'aime les pieds la position sur les
bonnes cases à chaque fois
donc tranquille
[Musique]
et voir ce qui se passe
tu as pas trop le choix après la tête
cavaler les bébés qui peut arriver avec
un cavalier 6 comme ça
[Musique]
en fait il y a aussi le fait qu'ils
mettent pas mal la pression à
autant maintenant
parce que là alors comme standard pour
venir en D6 je pense après ce qui est
bien toujours encore une fois c'est pas
facile à gérer
moi j'aime bien les Noirs ici je trouve
que il y a un problème de coordination
entre ces pièces là chez les Blancs et
c'est pas évident de vraiment faire un
truc
du temps cette position elle est
déséquilibrée quand même
il se trouve mal le temps encore Carona
j'ai envie de dire c'est presque pas de
sa faute c'est vraiment l'autre qui est
au dessus à ce niveau-là
non mais franchement je comprenais pas
les les prédictions qui donnaient
carbonara 70% franchement pour moi c'est
un compréhensible du coup c'est bizarre
que tu es parié sur
ce que tu as
mais
franchement
j'ai trouvé la magnifique excuse du
partenaire de club sauf elle est énorme
moi j'avais été partir de club aussi de
prendre Amanda à l'époque moi ça n'a pas
encore ça ne peut pas beaucoup servi
après j'ai vu j'ai vu que par exemple il
va participer au tata style 2022 tu
pourras peut-être te refaire c'est ça et
je compte bien me refaire là-dessus
parce que maintenant il a quand même
pris un an il a pris 100 points Hello
et écoute
[Musique]
la grosse Montana
est-ce que
on va voir passer
j'ai pas l'impression en fait
ouais
je pense que tu as
dans un match comme celui-là
il reste un quart d'heure quasiment un
peu plus sur le temps
et au final écoute ben je pense pas
qu'il va essayer de prendre tous les
risques
cette position ben tu vois si par
exemple carbonnage si je parle
[Musique]
la mentalité de ce genre de joueur c'est
vraiment c'est de gagner tout leur
partie je pense je les vois pas être
dans la dans le calcul quoi si tu veux
et
là il a l'air d'avoir quand même sacré
pose
à 5 qui passe pas tu as les pièces
noires sont trop actives
pour faire quelque chose
c'est bien joué
[Musique]
c'est un bon essai peut-être ce qui fait
là
si tu prends G7 je prends à 5 tu prends
H6 et puis écoute
à la même idée tu vas prendre
G7 je prends à 5 tu prends un justice en
tout cas il a plus de temps attendu
car wanna sur l'ensemble de la partie et
puis là écoute Marion il va tenter de
l'embêter déjà petit coup qui vient de
faire l'indique
[Musique]
il y aura aussi ce qui peut être faible
tranquille
mais je pense pas que il va juste
essayer de voir comme il est mal au
temps il a aucun risque à continuer ça
en avançant un petit peu
avec 8 secondes faut toujours se méfier
tu peux te prendre une belle carotte
je vois pas trop comment quand même mais
tu bouges le roi c'est nul
s en fait non bah non je passe pas je
passe pas mais il peut tourner quoi tu
vois sauf pour faire ça va essayer de
tourner de façon
la défense
c'est logique vous voyez même si les il
est très bien il y a pas trop de raison
que là je peux manger peut-être c'est ça
il peut y avoir des petites carottes
mais pour l'instant je dois pas sûr
parce que sur roller
[Musique]
parce que
là il va se pencher un petit peu sur la
position pour essayer de faire plier
mais c'est pas simple
je pense pas trop que
ça ça risque il y avait non il y avait
pas
va finir nul
mais tu vois il met la pression quand
même même dans cette finale de tour qui
est égal il est là quoi moi il veut
jouer aux échecs
attention comme ça
[Musique]
il fait juste
roi G2
ça c'est nul allez la finale
vous la connaissez
les pâtes
tu as vu il a posé des problèmes ça fait
peur au moment c'était pas si loin de
la pression jusqu'au bout
5 2
5 2 et c'est le dernier est-ce que c'est
le dernier non il y en aura un autre
après je pense
avec le plus 1 ça va être tout juste
plus un 12 minutes ouais ça peut être la
dernière partie sauf si ça finit
[Musique]
un petit peu avant donc ça c'est l'hymne
que je joue en fait pas vraiment mais je
joue ce genre de position avec
là tu as plusieurs plans un peu noir tu
peux laisser ses dessins ou tu peux
aussi faire C5 qui est excessif
non pas je pense à carwana toujours pas
une partie de gagner quoi c'est terrible
il était
en souffrance quoi ça fait une regard
qui joue et il a toujours pas toujours
pas gagné une partie c'est
il se bat bien il se bat bien il a il a
pris trois bulles 4 nuls c'est
hyper dur à avaler quoi parce qu'on
parle pas d'un petit joueur pendant des
meilleurs joueurs de tous les temps bon
tour bien trois B4 peut-être dans cette
position sauf
pour
pour Fabiano cavalier C2 cavaliers sans
doute peut-être
c'est pas grave
s'il devait pas jouer qui avoir lieu
trois avant
[Musique]
-bras
dans cette position donc lui non plus
peut-être d'ailleurs puisqu'il balance
A4
f56
que les blancs comme ils attaquent le
roi
je vais tout manger et puis
imaginons
je mets juste en place une petite
attaque
j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
d'ailleurs il a pris
B3 ok il est où la position directe
[Musique]
il est en train de de passer un peu à
côté de sa partie à rien parce que là
ce serait vraiment bon moral que pour
pour famille qui gagne cette partie
avant avant la pause et avant de passer
au prochain segment de Blitz tu vas
venir à 5 3 gagner une partie tu vois
bon
si facile encore tu vois moi je pensais
que c'était vraiment il est bien déconné
mais en fait faut prouver quoi faut
prouver bon après j'ai des meilleures
pièces et c'est clair mais là j'ai
peut-être mangé à deux et faire tomber
trois et trois
B80
d'échanger les pièces
il trouve toujours des bons coups très
très bien
il a un super côté pratique quand il
joue aussi
il y a plein de coups en a en plus
des trois c'est pas ridicule avec fou et
fin
on peut vous dire que donc là c'est
intéressant un centre bloqué vous
retenez attaque sur les ailes chaque
camp attaqué sur les ailes l'attaque
blanche a été plus lente à se développer
mais il voulait attaquer le roi
donc normalement on a le droit de partir
en retard sauf que là ça m'a mal tourné
pourquoi il a pas mangé quand même
[ __ ]
par principe j'ai du mal à accepter le
fait de pas avoir de Tours sur la 8ème
rangée ça me fait un peu peur
tour de deux va être joué je pense on
est bientôt à l'abandon parce que il y
aura les idées C4 C3 C2
il y a du échec là il y a tout B2 non là
c'est moi par confiance à Fabi pour la
gagner celle-là
c'était très bien mais là il s'est fait
écraser
OK
le cavalier E3 en l'air très simple
abandon direct et du coup on aura une
dernière partie dans ce segment
finalement
[Musique]
une dernière partie avec les Blancs pour
Caravana elle peut complètement revenir
là il peut relancer
[Musique]
et du coup il y a cinq trois premières
victoires de la clé blanc c'est un
dragon bah écoutez il revient à un point
de critique là il faut tout ranger ouais
c'est chaud
[Musique]
il y en a on voit que les Blancs un joli
jeu de pièces mais ils ont roi le roi
qui est un peu plus sous pression parce
que les pièces arrivent un peu plus vite
tout simplement mais normalement ça doit
tenir que les Blancs espèrent
en tout cas tu vois
Arjun qui est C avec les noirs de faire
que des ouvertures
dynamiques il y a des choses à faire il
veut pas se laisser écraser que la
partie précédente s'il est passé
vraiment à côté par rapport à ce qu'il
avait montré depuis le départ aussi
quasiment et là il a fait après c'est
normal d'avoir un peu une baisse de
régime tu peux pas être au max à tout le
temps
surtout à cette cadence là
il prend un jeu ok mais
attention que cette
je peux manger ou pas
il fait j'ai 4 ou tard j'ai eu peur au
début
en fait
je comprends pas ce qui se passait là
[Musique]
je suis bon alors attends il veut pas me
répondre ainsi que des 5 fois en fait
ok bon j'avais raison quand même
on l'expliquera carvana qu'on avait
raison alors Dame des deux
et là ça peut être très problématique
parce que tout est forcé et le cavalier
reste en l'air en dessin
c'est quand même très moche sa structure
on est obligé ou trop de direct il a
fait
[Musique]
un petit sourire
je casse tout chez moi
en tout cas là par les secourir son
temps
un jaune va être en grande difficulté
ok bon c'est pas encore si simple en
fait
non c'est pas simple du tout on avait
bossé
matériel c'est pas non plus
et j'ai pas le temps de faire prendre
les 5 je peux pas jouer F4
mais la structure quand même qui est
noir qui commence c'est faible
quand même pas mal mais faut pas oublier
que plus tard il y a aussi des idées
avec H5 qui était possible tu as juste
pour expliquer rapidement plus tard il y
a des caches 5 et contre jeux
et pas clair du tout le roi actif la
tension continue pour finir cette partie
ok je sens que je trouve ça intéressant
j'ai 5 qui l'empêche les aider avec H5
pour avoir pu passer et il empêche aussi
F6 F6 la Caballe prend le 6 du coup là
en fait il veut manger ici et après
garder les problèmes j'aime beaucoup le
changer 5
je trouve que c'est
parce que si jamais j'arrive maintenant
à manger là et faire ça et ben écoute tu
arrives pas t'activer comme dans l'autre
en fait
c'est un joli cours alors c'est un beau
fois F6
mais c'est peut-être doute il y a
peut-être cavalier ouais c'est chaud
quoi enfin tu vois je veux dire c'est
une idée structurel mais bon est-ce que
ça marche il y a peut-être tu pouvais
intercaler aussi il faut prendre des 5
avant et là il y a peut-être cavaliers
aussi c'est compliqué
vous voyez comme le pion G5 de carwan
Ahmed j'essaie de faire une sorte de
fourchette structurel quoi
F7 encore
on voit que là ça pourrait être sympa
ouais 5 mais il y a peut-être fou
prendre des 5 ans
et maintenant il prend pour éviter F6
maintenant
on va faire attention à pas trop aider
les Noirs dans la dans leur activité
mais poussez par là 7 et fixer un petit
peu la position noire avec le pion à 7
qui est là un petit haschiste pour pour
le contre jeu et passer le roi je peux
pas jouer F4 à cause d'âge du coup je
devrais sûrement manger pour apprendre
et après
[Musique]
tout recettes que tu as indiqué tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
si j'arrive à amener mon roi jusqu'en D4
à tour des 6 à Tours
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps de faire un truc tout
reprend F5 puis on prend un F6 ou
l'inverse pour faire la fourchette en
dessert F6 et du coup très très joli ce
F4 tu as vu souffle le jeu structurel
avec deux minutes à la pendule F4 il me
bloque la perspective F6 en fait vous
avez compris très vite que c'était malin
de jouer pour cela mais en fait
en difficulté tour à 3 et donc il peut
venir en D4 tandis que le temps
du coup ce sera la dernière partie dans
ce segment après il y aura une pause
encore de 5 minutes avant les trois puls
1 alors c'est quand même papa pareil si
dans cette dans cette partie il arrive à
gagner
tout le match
ce qui s'est quand même fait bien bien
démonter sur l'ensemble on va dire mais
là les deux dernières parties c'est
l'inverse ça fait du mal je trouve c'est
propre en plus et
bon dans la partie d'avant il est passé
à côté mais celle-là bah écoute
celle-là franchement mais moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé le GSM de Caravana qui est
très très fort
[Musique]
je suis comme content que ça s'arrête
cette période de 5 + 5 tu au pire un bon
petit 5 4 souffle voilà on encaisse les
subs déjà c'est pas mal heureusement
qu'il y a ça parce que je suis un peu
inquiet pour l'ensemble du match
j'étais hyper confiant mais
ok là bon je pense vu l'avance que tu
avais dans ce set tu avais gagné mais je
suis comme quelqu'un que pour l'intérêt
du match carvana qui se réveille alors
c'était un peu exagéré de dire qu'après
ce set ça pouvait être déjà plié mais au
vu de la dynamique si tu veux ça s'il y
avait un + 3 une dynamique ou karwana
n'avait pas remporté de parti ben on
pouvait s'attendre à quelque chose de
pas top
essayer il faudrait pouvoir jouer
pour achat de quelque chose il a pas le
choix c'est trop passif
je trouve que c'est beau quoi tu vois il
a compris
cette position
faudrait pouvoir sacrifier le faux et
gagner le dernier pion
pour parce que la finale roi tour
cavalier contre roi tour est nul assez
facilement
et comment on continue comment on pousse
ses pions
il veut encore tu vois poser des
problèmes avec sa tour
et roi C4 il y a pas de fou qu'elle va
les prendre à chaque fois et il veut
jouer sans que la B5 qui va encaisser le
cavalier
[Musique]
toujours un peu frustrant de mettre son
cavalier devant le pion le roi c'est un
peu dans le même état d'esprit
[Musique]
sans doute ce pion
tu manges le pion
les deux idées soit on allait croquer le
pion soit en contrôle d'abord BK parce
qu'on peut aller le chercher avec le roi
aussi
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas bête de
faire une sorte
de blocus là parce que roi à 5 tours
donc Fabiano il vient la rescousse un
petit peu
mieux
et du coup c'est pour ça qu'on arrive
pas voilà donc Fabiano a empêché Roy F4
avec ton rêve F2 mais maintenant il y a
roi des 4 avec
est-ce que j'ai tout ras de là Tour
Radio
voilà c'est chaud c'est le money time ça
peut me se perdre ce genre de position
revient il a pas voulu faire ça
et maintenant faut vite se dépêcher
d'aller sacrifier son fou sur le pion
il a aussi envie de laisser
en tout cas ça c'est obscurci là pour
Fabiano
on devrait essayer de commencer à aller
essayer de certifier la camel sur
6 secondes toujours il arrive à mettre
une pression de folie ou trop vite en
fait ça va être horrible à la fin
c'est déjà perdu c'est déjà c'est chaud
elle va laisser des traces
pas d'une oreille quoi tu vois elle est
assez peu démonstratif
voilà
content voilà mais il y a pas de d'excès
de zèle quoi on voit Fabiano lui était
plus vert c'est normal franchement il a
dominé toute la partie magnifique partie
de Fabiano et la défense est juste
stratosphérique quoi
grande difficulté mais ça marche pas bon
on vous on vous rejoint des 5 minutes on
passe dans une petite
page de pub
donc le segment de 5 + 1 se terminer
avec 6 3 pour irigasi incroyable quand
même c'est indien qui
démonstration en tout cas c'était ce
qu'on pensait avant quoi en tout cas il
a été très dominateur quand même sur
l'ensemble de cette après 6-3 je trouve
un peu cher plus deux ça aurait été je
pense sur le truc normal et là + 3 non
c'est pas normal quoi
donc du coup
dans un autre endroit pour la pour trois
plus une ok
de de une plus une à tout de suite allez
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc dans la phase la phase 3 + 1 cette
fois-ci avec du coup
avec du coup un score de 6-3 pour
erikasi dans cette phase donc on a on va
avoir une heure deux trois plus une donc
trois plus ça va quand même très très
vite un jack 5 plus ça évite la 5 + une
ça va encore plus vite et
ericasi qui depuis le début je joue très
très vite quand même ce match et qui
on a le droit à des petites variantes en
plus des petits sous variantes pour pour
embêter carwana avec une sorte d'attaque
torrell là puisque le Fou est en G5
c'est un début de Londres avec le fond
en G5 voilà du grand classique mais
c'est vrai qu'ils jouent très très vite
c'est horrible donc c'est horrible pour
kerwana quoi parce qu'en plus il perd
même des positions qui sont des fois
avantageuses parce que l'autre lui met
une telle pression à la pendule que
c'est vraiment difficile à chaque fois
d'y faire face
[Musique]
ce 3 plus simple parce que dans le 5 + 1
c'est vraiment au temps
ou irrégaliser a réussi à faire mal du
coup en 3 + 1 ça devrait être encore
pire avoir car wanna c'est un champion
dans sa seule partie gagnée il a marché
sur organisé donc il peut quand même lui
faire mal de temps en temps de temps en
temps
là attention parce qu'on est
on est dans des troubles au centre pour
faire très très attention dans ces
positions là ça peut vite vriller terme
de structure de pion et de ça c'est
normal faut prendre si c'est le coup
qu'on avait envie de jouer avant et E4
ok on libère tout il va pas se passer
grand chose dans cette partie ça c'est
clair
je vois bien tous échanger au centre
et ça devrait ça devrait s'égaliser
bon bah j'ai eu tort il n'a pas joué ça
n'a pas il a dû juger que dame cavalier
contre dame français un petit peu plus
fort
du coup il a pas tout pris en 4 alors
comment on joue maintenant parce que si
on fait 5 avaler 7 est-ce qu'on a assez
pour pour aller sur le roi
c'est jouer en tout cas B4 x 7 et
maintenant s'organise cavalier B3 pour
le passer en D4 et il va bloquer le
centre
aryoun et il va tenter il va tenter
d'avancer sur la loi donc là le plan
d'amener deux d'un F4 ça c'est sûr
cavalier B3 en D4 il faut faire gaffe au
pion c'est du coup réaction directe il a
cru Fabiano que Arion avait assez pour
l'attaquer donc il ouvre le centre pour
pas prendre une attaque un peu type
du coup F6 bien joué
jaloux du centrale verts jaloux de la
perspective d'attaque on joue à 6
d'autant plus qu'on a la paire de fou
et si on a la paire de fou dans cette
position avec la noire faut quand même
normalement ouvrir la position
le jeu de couleur indique qu'on est les
seuls à avoir le foot 15 noir donc il
faut ouvrir les cases noires les blancs
eux ils ont trois pièces mineures qui
peuvent aller sur les cases blanches
alors que les noirs n'ont que deux donc
faudrait plutôt ouvrir les cases
blanches
voilà comment ça se passe le jeu de
couleurs donc FO B8 mise en place
du jeu de couleur sur noir prise
abscisse dame prend la dame sur cars
et la perspective aussi comme on le
disait tout à l'heure le pion c'est trop
est attaqué mais on veut faire E5 aussi
E54
il y a quand même un problème qu'il faut
régler
un problème le plus le pion c'est trop
en l'air et la perspective de 5 ça
pourrait faire très très mal
salut yoyo pour stuff au platine
technique
comme vous le voyez
j'arrive
cavalier FD4 alors qu'est-ce qui a été
prévu sur E5 peut-être non cavalier F5
c'est pas jouable qu'est-ce qui va
prévoir cavalier F5 mais qu'est-ce qu'il
y a vu sur E4 alors E4 il a sûrement
trouver quelque chose ok il y a la
fourchette en U7 mais ça passe ça peut
pas être ça le 4 simplement fous prends
le 4 puis on prend le 4 dames prends des
ça se joue à fond la caisse en plus
d'un point de 7 il est content dans
cette position là ça faisait peur de
rentrer là-dedans tout rêve ça de jouer
par Fabiano est-ce que ça a pas été un
oubli Darius ce que je vois parce qu'il
faut jouer sur ton rêve 7
bon bah je vois pas parce que il y a pas
terminé
suivre
là ça a été
il y a une grosse faute de calcul
Darius voilà
[Musique]
c'était chaud
j'ai regardé ça ce matin donc ça je peux
vous dire que c'est normalement un bon
petit pouce blanc c'est confortable mais
visiblement à ryoun il est pas trop pas
trop inquiet alors pourquoi je dis un
petit plus blanc confortable on a un
gros fou de casse blanche voilà il
Fabiano a joué la totale le plan
classique
attention à tout moment il peut prendre
en H2 bien sûr pour l'instant il y a B7
mais il est capable on sait
il y a pas trop de problèmes d'accord H4
alors H4 go
B5 donc on a vu que Fabiano avait waouh
voilà Nice il a mis son roi à l'abri du
côté de l'aile dame du coup il se fait
agresser alors là sacrifice à tempo de
Fabiano qui dit attention je vais je
vais gagner en force ton kssi c'est la
du monde si vous voulez il y a un double
clouage il y a le courage absolu fubé
5.8 le clouage relatif tours ces deux
dames C7
et du coup la séquence est tourcéen
d'Ama 4 est foutu quoi
donc là je pense qu'il va jouer tour
c'est un pour continuer le pressing
ouais ça semble logique parmi ces jouets
du coup dans cette position maintenant
comment on va faire roi des 7 ça paraît
hyper dur à tenir
incroyable la vitesse
de calcul OK dans ma carte c'est quoi
j'ai pas compris dans ma carte comment
on fait Dame des 7
on est toujours dans les troupes dans ma
carte jouet
comment je gère la pression sur G2
en tout cas pour l'instant Fabiano est
bien réveillé
parce que ça fait deux raclettes de
suite je devrais partir je crois que je
suis parti en pause les gars
transfiguré j'avais pas vu fou D8 qui
est très malin bien sûr surtout reprend
ses 8 dames prend dans ma 4 parce
qu'avant c'est tout repensé 8 sur échec
mais je crois pas du tout la position
Dario c'est juste deux pions de moins
avec un peu d'application je suis sûr
que
Fabiano va bien faire le travail
bon c'est peut-être peut-être parfois 5
qui doit pas être pas être stupide
encore que 6
on peut jouer pour Beckham B5 ce qui est
un peu pénible c'est la pression sur
g2d2 alors comment on gagne cette
position c'est pas si facile quand même
ok peut-être juste damasis damassis ou
d'un B5 voilà et puis après on va on va
envoyer le pion a
et là le pion a va être dur à arrêter
pas de contre je
à 4 à 5 à 6
voilà c'est le parti quand même
en tout cas dur dur dur dur dans
celle-là
quand le 3 + 1 on attendait à arioune
hyper dominateur vu sa rapidité bah il
en est rien
après c'est cool comme de voir que
Carona revient dans ce match moi ça me
fait ça me fait plaisir
au bord du gouffre
et on va envoyer
voilà
qui réfléchit il accuse un peu le coup
Fabi qui a son petit son petit sourire
le dernier bluff de la position
un petit coup d'échec roi C2
et il essaie d'embrouiller
va monter en B3 voilà Fabiano il peut se
cacher avec A4 et roi à deux
donc tout rede bien sur dame pro et de
dames françaises
bon et même ça est-ce que ça suffirait
pas forcément mais bon
on tient la pause ok D4
très intéressant dernier move
on tente tout chez rayon mais faut
prendre des cartes il y a pas la case
des 5 pour la dame alors que faire
roi et fluide il essaie de planquer son
roi
à 4 tiens la dame B5 en plus pour éviter
les arnaques
là on peut vraiment plus bouger
pourquoi j'ai 8 hop pour sortir son roi
du feu
et maintenant là c'est bientôt fini là
je peux vous le dire tour des 6 fait
très mal ok terminé trop de matériel en
plus on va voir comment Arion va réussir
il vient de faire 2-0 de suite et quand
même on voit Fabiano et retrouve le
sourire il pense au sub qui va faire
récupérer à stouffe ça ça fait mal ça ça
fait très très mal
ok donc on est dans un début
versé dans ses débuts assez
rigolo assez rare des soulignes pour
aller chercher son adversaire
donc on est dans une position vraiment
tout à fait classique ici
de cette variante de cette variante
alors le coût H4 c'est encore comme
Arion n'aime bien le faire je balance
tous mes pions sur l'aile roi et je
boucle le centre au préalable à 4 c'est
normal il verrouille le cavalier en B5
qui domine le cavalier à 6 il va faire
ses trois à un moment
et du coup cavalier 5 c'est 3 c'est du
classique foudet 3 s'il peut et G4 et je
balance tous mes pions aller droit s'il
a le temps de faire tout ça il le fera
c'est pour ramener le cavalier en C6 on
pourrait voir ces trois fous des trois
c'est pas impossible
moi j'ai 4 direct pas chercher à
comprendre il pousse tous ses pions sur
le roi de Fabiano
il le secours il essaie d'aller le
chercher en tactique
est-ce qu'on
pourrait voir ou non le retour
terrible de fabianowa avec trois sur
trois bah écoute j'ai envie de te dire
oui
je pense que carvana dans ce match il
pense au sub perdu partout
et comme il m'aime bien tu vois il a pas
envie de se bloque très vite
et dans ce match là en fait là où il
avait été surprenant car voilà c'était
dans les cadences plus rapides et ce qui
est assez incroyable parce que
généralement
tu vois depuis des années on dit oui
mais il est pas très loin en bus carwana
oui mais tu vois et en fait contre mvl
bah plus la commence accélérer plus il
était fort
propre et aussi bon ça un peu avoir
aussi mais
oui j'ai fait une petite erreur de
j'avais pas vu tu vois elle était belle
celle-là
pour voir si vous suiviez tous les gars
exactement et du coup bah je vous
félicite de de bien suivre je suis
content de voir que on n'est pas les
seuls à parler comme ça
et du coup oui la semaine dernière on a
quand même
on a quand même carvana qui a gagné le
tatouage
il se chauffe et donc bon c'est les
trois plus une et
je pense qu'il s'est je pense qu'il a
essayé de bosser un peu cette année il a
quand même pris 100 points et l'eau
aussi
Kawana 100 points
en blitz
mondial d'ailleurs maintenant
on va devoir relire le livre de Sami
Kevin
ça c'est clair
non mais là
regarde là il est en fait il a un style
de jeu
hyperactif un petit peu bancal
ouais ça marche pas parce que
il a dû oublier il a dû oublier regarder
la tête Dario
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe oulala il pensait avoir [ __ ]
les gars il pense avoir ça mignon mais à
la fin il y avait la fourchette qui
récupère la dame incroyable et même à ce
niveau là ça fait des gaffes et je pense
que même comme ça c'était dur pour les
blancs non parce que j'ai l'impression
que le roi blanc au centre
je sais pas voilà maintenant ça tire la
tronche à cette position donc ça fait
tomber le centre pour attaquer 3-0 quand
même en blitz c'est quand même quand
même pas mal cette histoire
c'est un peu la crise j'avoue que tu
m'as bien eu tu m'as fidélisé un peu
comme les joueurs dans les parcs tu m'as
laissé la première tu m'as laissé les
premiers substouf pour mieux m'enfoncer
derrière c'est plein de malice que tu as
fait moi j'y ai cru
et maintenant je peux vous dire carioune
cette position ben voilà c'est terminé
il est content je peux vous dire il fait
plus du tout la même tête il a des
petits sourires là et ouais qu'il a
revenu au score du coup il est revenu au
score donc on a 6 6 tout d'un coup avec
3 0 3 0 est-ce que tu mets un petit peu
de bonus en cas de Fanny
avec les Blancs
c'est dur c'est dur
moi j'aime bien ces pollution avec les
Blancs avoir l'espace comme ça les
droits j'aime beaucoup les positions
fermées avec de l'espace
d'ailleurs bon rien n'est spécialiste de
française mais ça ne variante là je
l'aime pas trop mais bon après il va
nous faire mentir vraisemblablement mais
c'est vrai que on va pas trop où sont
les problèmes blanc on a juste perdu la
casse B3 mais on a réussi à ouvrir des
perspectives des fois il y a des idées à
base de fou à 4 ou ces deux fous ici
le fou devient là et le fou il est
mauvais derrière ses pions mais quand il
passe de la structure et ben le foot
vient fort donc ça c'est une idée
française
je pense qu'il a appris un petit coup au
moral dans cette cadence à Rio on
parlait tout à l'heure de Fabiano qui
avait vécu comme une sale heure et demie
là en 45 minutes se prendre trois zéros
et avoir les Noirs bon bah il va falloir
être fortement un quart d'heure
un quart d'heure à 3 euros un quart
d'heure oui oui c'est pas trop 3/4
d'heure un quart d'heure 3 - 0 c'est
hyper dur
donc du coup est-ce qu'il va s'en sortir
avec le petit fou à deux qui menace de
de je crois que c'est le dollar de
l'argile à toi il me semble l'expression
je sais pas si tu connais
sur la chaîne de stream je crois c'est
le fait de manger une tour comme ça avec
un fou enfermé je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est le thème le terme mais
je suis pas spécialiste mais du coup ça
aurait pu être drôle de faire cavaluer
un food
j'ai vu la référence parce que j'ai déjà
vu un live sur la chaîne donc il me
semble que c'est ça
alors du coup 7
donc l'idée des blancs quand même ça va
être d'essayer de jouer contre le fou le
four à 4 s'il faut arrive à se mettre en
jeu il peut être quand même assez fort
sur la diagonale mais il a réussi à
gérer l'initiative blanche pour
l'instant rayonne un moment j'étais un
peu plus inquiet que ça il faut dire
qu'ils ont pas un temps infini non plus
hein
il adore dans tous ces parties s'il peut
prendre du matériel là dehors il le
prend et c'est une manière de prendre un
peu l'initiative
dans un point de vue et mais bon là il y
a quand même des pièces qui sont pas
super complètement
à jouer
8 tempo pas le choix il fallait régler
le problème la Tour Eiffel
je sais pas comment on va s'en sortir
avec cette tour
d'ailleurs il appuie dessus
la tour et repartir après en G6 donc il
y a eu F5 tempo pour ouvrir la diagonale
le fils de la vie blanc et F5
un petit peu
les trois victoires de suite qui font du
bien pour balancer des coups comme ça
tempo
à chauffer en [ __ ] là franchement
on le voit tout à l'heure
une tête
bien abattue et là c'est complètement
inverse il y a 20 minutes il voulait
mourir et là en fait les gars il bois
son eau il est tranquille
roi des 8 on sent que là c'est déjà les
coups on est un peu à l'agonie on essaie
de
faire tout de suite qui qui est un peu
en PLS ça se passe complètement parce
qu'on voit il est pas démonstratif mais
là c'est clair que ça va pas du tout
cavalier prend E5 puis on prend il a
prévu de donner la qualité ouais mais ça
on sent que c'est quand même l'aveu
d'impuissance je pense que ça va juste
perdre en force cette position je vois
pas du tout pourquoi cette position
tiendrait puisque permet de résister
mais pas du tout de gagner cette
position ni de faire nulle
c'est très très dur de toute façon il y
aura tout F6 tours G1 roi des 4 et du
coup là ça va gagner tout seul
vraisemblablement
la prise de la de la colonne quand même
quelque chose de très important c'est
hyper facile là
de partout là
qui va
trouver une belle petite ressource de
jouer avec H5
maintenant c'est un peu plus difficile
de passer mais je pense que c'est quand
même gagnant
du coup à l'arrache mais je vais
défendre des cartes
ça m'a l'air trop dur en fait tu montes
les Noirs ils vont quand même contre jeu
en fait mais c'est pas c'est pas
suffisant
puis moi je peux
être le coup critique mais à tout Roger
cinq projets 6 attention
il peut manger aussi je pense qu'il peut
se permettre
[Musique]
la tour et c'est pas simple de ramener
la tour parce qu'il y a toujours F5 le
jour où je vais venir sur la planète
on pourrait avoir si un jour tu pourrais
fin je peux peut-être des fois ça qui
n'est pas pour l'instant pour l'instant
je dois atterrir de moins non je peux
pas me permettre de faire ça je regarde
garder mes tours ou alors regarder mon
pion
je pense bon pas trop trouver mais les
gens je vais vous montrer
maintenant il y a les idées de Tours F1
et surtout
F5
qui est ici donc en fait on le roi passe
quand même sauve par roi f43 G5 il est
en train de montrer ça d'ailleurs il
ramène le roi là-bas comme quoi
c'est vraiment important
on peut faire mal à la défense il va
bloquer
ça perce de partout finalement il
revient de ce côté là
il va sacrifier le fou
c'est le football
je rentre
il a compris direct et joue B4 pour
compliquer on s'en fout là je vais juste
manger je pense
ouverte c'est une bonne nouvelle
qui
était au fond du trou qui maintenant
prend l'avantage le format il est quand
même terrible ça il y a des gros
retournements quand même qui sont
possibles on pose la faire coller
plusieurs fois comme vous le voyez
parce que la 4-0 en blitz
il reste encore une demi-heure donc
après au niveau du score c'est comme 7-6
hein c'est pas c'est pas énorme comme
c'est sûr mais ça doit lui faire du bien
car Wana il pouvait être au fond du trou
après cette séquence à la place il est
devant quoi c'est incroyable c'est clair
non c'est juste ouf
c'est juste ouf
mais écoutez je suis assez content de
Paris
quand je vois ce tableau des scores
stouf je suis en train de le regarder
plusieurs fois pour savoir si je ne rêve
pas si je passe un cauchemar c'est
terrible quoi
en Top 12 et 28
tu demanderas de payer les subst
remboursement
quoi j'étais vraiment
confort
mais bon le 4-0 fait mal je vois sa
petite tête là
je pense que tout à l'heure j'ai parlé
du football ça lui a fait peut-être peur
tu vois et du coup ça va peut-être
passer
[Rires]
bon ce qui est bien c'est que là il a
l'air d'avoir un avantage un petit peu
stable
une vraie stopper l'hémorragie
quand même de française des changes un
petit peu différente
mais bon c'est un petit peu pénible mais
s'il arrive à défendre tranquillement
des trois fuites et tout c'est bizarre
[Musique]
il y aura de la main c'est ça à chaque
fois à ma carte
il va me faire échec il va manger là et
puis il y a quand même plein d'échecs
maintenant
très fort
quand même
il y a un petit plus blanc cette fois-ci
là et on voit pousser on voit en plus le
pion qui va contrôler la diagonale que
tous les échecs bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr important aussi
en fait c'est la vitesse d'exécution
c'est surtout ça qui est fou je trouve
c'est déjà dur mais
la vitesse à laquelle ils font tout ça
je trouve que c'est justement ce truc là
donc maintenant il faut réussir à
pousser le pion des mais pas se
retrouver à se faire perpéter si on fait
des cinq dci s'il y a la case F4 ça peut
être pénible parce que je peux pas trop
pousser le pion en fait à cause de
vous voyez dès que le pion passe d'ici
voilà s'il fait des six il y a échecs
ça peut être là du coup
[Musique]
par exemple
à tout prix donc là sûrement de 3 G8
et sur dameuse 5 je pensais à juste en
fait et je me disais bon
il y a des chances hein
pas bon parce qu'il y a pion passé
protéger et si j'arrive là je fais mes
cinq
comme ça il y a plus d'âme 5 pour se
mettre derrière on contrôle maintenant
sur est-ce que je peux programmer que
les noirs ou pas
au pire j'ai ça
[Musique]
c'est du coup après les pions de la
valeur
moi je vois une nul ici
je pense que c'est trop trop risqué
[Musique]
mais il a pas réussi il s'est fait
doubler en vélo de chaise.com aussi
on a compris
d'une pause là
[Musique]
du coup encore une petite pause est-ce
que tu veux faire une petite pause
et on revient tout de suite à tout de
suite
[Musique]
on est de retour avec Kevin pour cette
deuxième partie du 3 + 1 deuxième 7 donc
Kevin j'ai quand même une bonne nouvelle
pour toi
reghazi vient de faire sa son premier
match nul dans ce set ce qui veut dire
que tu ne seras pas Fanny
c'est cool ça fait plaisir sauf que tu
le tu le mentionnes je te remercie
pour 7 dans ce sac pas du tout dans le
match je sais plus quoi penser mais je
pense que la petite pause elle a fait du
bien à Rona franchement
ouais complètement et tout à l'heure on
a vu un la pause qui a qui a qui a bien
aidé car wanna qui était mené trois 6-3
lors du premier set et qui met quatre
points d'affilée en 3 + 1 donc là au
final un match super serré avec chacun
qui est assez haut et ses bas donc 7,5
pour pour l'instant car wanna qui mène
d'un point encore beaucoup de choses à
faire on a encore une demi-heure de de
Blitz en 3 + 1 et ensuite du Bullet en
trois plus une en une plus une pardon
une demi-heure aussi donc on va voir un
petit peu comment ça va cliquer
dans tous les cas on donnait grâce à
plus la cadence avance plus
selon nous est gaziers de favoris et
bien finalement le premier set surtout
avec le premier set était dominateur au
niveau du temps donc on se disait que ça
allait être encore pire en plus hein bon
c'est bien trompé et du coup depuis
depuis
ben à la fin du premier set et ben là on
a compris en fait que Kawana ils vendait
pas la peau de l'ours
[Musique]
et au final et ben écoutez kavana a pris
a pris la tête dans ce business et du
coup on va voir un peu comment se
termine ce 7 les parties commencent à
l'instant
c'est parti une petite anglaise et on
est parti on clique
donc ça joue vite encore une fois
des deux alors ça je suis absolument
hors théorie je sais pas si attention il
va mettre sans doute le fond en Détroit
après du coup ça ressemble un truc
4 et du coup la pack de fous des deux
sera assez limité est-ce que tu peux
nous expliquer un petit peu ce [ __ ] le
tour de rien
pour moi c'est hyper bizarre honnêtement
de jouer ça comme ça il doit considérer
que il est mieux développé que les
leviers centraux seront plus favorables
à de la tour en des reins mais bon tu
vois c'est pas très probant finalement
le Fou est venu en Détroit
pas trop ce que ce que ça a apporté à la
position c'est juste un petit peu noyer
le poisson entre guillemets c'est pas
que généralement la tour ouverte
et du coup ok j'ai pas l'impression que
ce soit une franche réussite pour
l'instant l'ouverture des blancs c'est
pas non plus une catastrophe mais
là par rapport à certaines ouvertures
avec ces 5 peut-être que la tour D1
était bien placée mais comme il y a
jamais eu ces 5 la tour D1 du coup est
pas justifiée actuellement on fera n'est
pas il y a pas de trucs incroyable qui
qui ressort de cette séquence ou des
deux tours d'air
souvent dans ces positions là on préfère
que vous soit sorti en F4 au G5 c'est
pas possible mais
plus possible d'ailleurs
ok petit travail à la dame quand même
parce que là on va envoyer du lourd avec
du G5 ou des choses comme ça ça se fait
dans certains cas surtout dans ce type
de confrontation avec une cadence hyper
rapide
peut aussi faire roi H8 pour pas avoir
les problèmes sur sur la diago les rois
c'est hyper thématique la tour à 8 fois
6 l'idée
sûrement de riz alors ça c'est vraiment
l'idée je pense que cinq cavaliers B6 kg
est-ce que c'est pas malin de changer de
fou d'abord
parce que ce fou c'est comme ça que le
bon fou des blancs celui-là le mauvais
alors faut assiste malheur du coup être
un coup assez assez intéressant
mais vu qu'il ne joue pas je me pose la
question pourtant ça m'a l'air d'être
pas mal fois si ça très intéressant sauf
six en tout cas moi je l'aurais fait et
je ferai sûrement perdu d'une manière
qu'on ne voit pas mais à cause de fois 6
tu échanges le bon fouet alors on vous
rappelle encore sur le chat que que nous
on vous fait les commentaires sans
ordinateur mais c'est vraiment de de
vous montrer un petit peu
comment les humains pensent aux échecs
comment les humains
à réfléchissent et et puisque voir
l'ordinateur illustre répéter les coûts
de l'ordi bah ça tout le monde peut le
faire et du coup ben je trouve que c'est
un peu moins intéressant du coup des
fois on propose des énormités on propose
des mauvais coups ça arrive parce
qu'encore une fois on est humain mais je
pense que c'est plus sympa pour vous en
tout cas de pouvoir suivre
son ordi je pense que vous en pensez foi
moi je trouve que c'est mieux non mais
il a il a il a craqué un pion tu as vu
sauf c'est ouais il a craqué un pion
avec les Blancs
parce que il a mis un Cavaillon E5
mais bon ben il va je sais 4 il y a un
pion passé qui arrive pas manger ici
parce qu'il perdent 5 normalement
[Musique]
encore une fois la pose qui porte
préjudice à celui qui mène et
franchement ici bah écoute
pas terrible
bons amis sur un 4,5 il aura pas le
temps
en plus c'est pas bête mais aussi bien
sûr non quand même 4-0 c'est quand même
énorme
il se l'ai pris tout à l'heure mais
je doute quand même car là ce qu'on se
prennent comme
4-0ana comme quoi la pause elle a un peu
cassé quand même qu'il était hyper
facile et là il fait quand même une très
mauvaise partie avec les Blancs pour un
joueur de son niveau de son talent
c'est vraiment une partie un peu ratée
après c'est des cadences hyper rapide
donc nous on sait bien sauf que quand on
joue à ces cadence hyper rapide des fois
on peut sortir une bonne partie et des
fois des bonnes des bonnes
parties mais dans le mauvais sens du
terme voilà après c'est pas encore c'est
simple on se pose parce que il faut
exploiter 5 fois 6 peut-être manger B6
il y a peut-être qui peut faire un
blocus donc bien entendu les blancs sont
beaucoup moins bien mais c'est pas
encore si clair de savoir comment les
Noirs vont procéder pour un pour pousser
leurs pions et si jamais j'arrive à
mettre un cavalier en baissant peut-être
le fond en C3 et tu vois
ça fait quand même ça fait quand même du
mal poussé 6 bien joué il doit bien la
case cavalier français c'est une belle
concession de donner ce fameux cavalier
E5
fou qui est pas très bon qui avait qui
était quand même bien placé au siège
dans l'air des fois
les CV quoi je pense même à un truc du
style cavalier à deux fous ces trois
peut-être une carotte sur la Torah 5
quoi ah oui effectivement il y a un
vis-à-vis donc une fois que tu fais des
cinq en tant qu'avant les prendre à me
prendre la Dame des fois plus la tour et
du coup je peux faire un petit cavalier
prend le cas peut-être
aussi une possibilité pour mettre un
camping 4
donc là il protège la tour B4 si il se
prend là super 1 donc tu viens défendre
du coup le fou à un menace fou B4 mais
tu restes cloué quand même
maintenant
30 secondes 45 hein
ok cavalue
mais ça va peut-être pas suffire parce
que maintenant c'est le monnaie mais on
sait que c'est hyper dangereux pour les
deux joueurs c'est parti dans le bon
état
qui va être joué avec la pression donc
c'est pas c'est pas clair enfin pour les
deux je pense que c'est compliqué
peut-être G4 G5 pour essayer quelque
chose H3 déjà petit coup on sait jamais
la calicie à C4 qui est possible donc il
a proposé aussi B4 aussi va être une
idée un jour
mais bon après la prise je suis pas sûr
que ça ça aide beaucoup les les blancs
en BK qui veulent jouer maintenant je
vais vite en punaise des fois à peine
jouait un tour à 4 pour ils ont leur
plan en tête tu vois franchement moi je
trouve ça hyper impressionnant la
capacité ce qui ont a vraiment pouvoir
jouer leur plan vite la B40 même
à jouer à peu près stratégique mais le
truc c'est que quand la cadence est très
réduite vraiment on fait sauf qu'il peut
on
reste assez simple regardant 8 jouer et
puis maintenant les pions avant c'est là
là ça fait mal c'est
3b3
il a quand même fait qu'un radié aussi
pour essayer de faire des petits des
petits trucs
peut-être un blocus comme ça
attention au temps chaque fois il faut
faire vraiment gaffe
attention
non non
peut être une idée attention
G4 attention
c'était possible sur la finale
pas se faire avoir des deux côtés du
temps c'est compliqué crois H6 oh là là
il y a pas d'échec ouh là là il prend
des risques là mais deux joueurs
d'ailleurs les rois qui se baladent
incroyable cette partie
c'est intéressant aussi est nul
incroyable cette défense de carwana en
cette partie complètement incroyable
cette défense de carvana
il était vert à Rieux il voulait
continuer mais il s'attendait pas à ce
que qui répétition on l'a vu hein il est
pas content
allez reste 21 minutes dans ce 7 de 3 +
1 le 7 je crois que je fais une croix
dessus maintenant sous j'avais une
espérance un peu secrète que ça vrille à
ce moment-là tu vois avec sa vienne mais
deux nul c'est pas suffisant là c'est
pas si 5-1 c'est pas bon ça
de se prendre un petit pastis là pour
pour
5 1 dans le 7 quoi
du coup on est reparti pour ce même type
d'ouverture là Dario avec début de
Londres il nous a fait l'attaque il nous
a fait tous les petits débuts des 4 sans
C4 c'est à dire qu'il ne joue pas le
grand bidame il joue des cartes pions
les petits matchs comme ça d'essayer
plein de petits schémas qui sera qui se
rapprochent de ça par exemple moi
j'avais vu j'avais vu aussi le match
Nakamura contre mvl unakamura avec les
Blancs il jouait il joue que des quatre
il rentre juste je suis désolé de te
couper
ça les cavaliers G5 derrière
[Musique]
mvl contre
Damas 3 et il veut ça tout le temps tout
le match il a fait ça toujours la même
et avec les Noirs mais et en fait il a
préparé deux trucs à fond avec plein de
possibilités à chaque fois des fois il
devient un petit peu mais toujours il
restait sur le même schéma et la même
ouverture et la même ligne en plus et du
coup il a rendu fou mvl
il avait gagné le match
le format s'y prête bien là c'est chaud
par contre pour une fois j'ai
l'impression que rien n'a un peu plus de
jeux que d'habitude dans ces petits
débuts alors on a une petite remarque là
pour savoir si
ta boisson et du pastis ou non ah non
non alors absolument pas moi je bois de
voilà c'est c'est un verre de bière
d'ailleurs tropical c'est c'est une
marque de bière en Espagne mais je bois
de l'eau gazeuse j'ai du parler à côté
tu vois je explicite un
ferventifs c'est ça les sportifs
j'adore quand
c'est
une boisson à boire toute ma vie je
pense que je boirai ça
j'arrêterai tout non mais franchement
non
ça prête à sourire quand même je suis
sérieux
là il a fait un petit sourire donc ça
veut dire que c'était quand même hyper
marrant je pense qu'il est comme moi il
bosse un petit Perrier entre les parties
quoi ouais je suis pas sûr qu'il se
fasse des shooters ça c'est sûr
il a une gourde je pense que ça il a une
gourde de Perrier quoi
normalement ça ça
peut stabiliser mais il a réussi à se
défendre quand même de manière assez
esthétique avec F5 aussi c'est bizarre
mais
sinon on sentait que ça pouvait aller et
tout va trouver le coup
je sais pas je peux pas vous dire pour
l'instant
par rapport à ce qu'on fait les plantes
3 ça ça a vraiment dans ce sens quoi ça
c'est assez logique merde qu'est-ce que
tu avais prévu sur cavalier 4 souffre
parce que là je suis un peu du tout mais
en fait au final je suis j'aime pas trop
ce que fait
ergasi
il a un poil enfermé
et bien nul tu vas bien j'ai cru que ça
c'était pas mal en fait peut-être tour
E5
jouer actif on sait que les gens actif à
chaque fois ces pièces tout F3 on fait
des petits coups
j'ai l'impression que c'est un petit peu
la partie de Bullet ça c'est c'est un
peu bizarre ce qui se passe c'est pas
normal
il chauffe pour après non mais tu vois
la position des pièces c'est un peu
bizarre
c'est un peu bizarre
il est hyper créatif et
ils adorent les hâtives c'est vraiment
intéressant après moi c'est plus la
vieille école c'est plus sérieux tu vois
dans les positions complexes il est il
est bien présent bon là c'est vraiment
le bazar quoi il y a du dames français 4
à tout moment du fout aussi ce cavalier
aussi mais on a la Toure F3 qui est sur
le rayon du Fou B7
prenais enfin j'aurais pu défendre
quelque part mais il y aura toujours des
problèmes de partout avec sur la case
blanche chaque fois aussi ce qui avait
aussi
et du coup
enlever le fou de casse blanche qui dit
[Musique]
en tout cas ça fait réfléchir car wanna
d'avoir un petit peu au temps à regarder
il est con il complique le truc
et j'ai pas tout ré 8 en plus derrière
un petit peu bouger sa tour et peut-être
fou c'est simple tout simplement on voit
qu'il a beaucoup de jeux
peut-être qu'il veut juste jouer actif
en fait tout rêve
les deux rois sont bizarres dans mage
quand est-ce que c'est jouable pourquoi
pas
c'est logique
on peut pas jouer dans le français
[Musique]
le droit de faire un coup comme ça
là ça va plus trop
10 secondes contre 10 secondes par
contre c'est la position prise en marche
aussi qui va arriver à un moment pour
lui pour l'instant faut faire attention
encore
[Musique]
recette au G7 mais j'ai peur d'être mon
roi sur la case blanche
j'avais oublié et les feux de
le Bullet ça risque d'être compliqué
quand même qui qui a un peu moins Triki
tu vois ouais en tout cas ça bastonne
franchement c'est hyper agréable comme
match
c'est clair donc encore un défi de ce
que là donc il reste encore 13 minutes
en segment 3 + 1 avec 8,8 pour l'instant
en compteur
avec les Blancs
c'est vraiment gros gros niveau
bien vous savez les curieux de manière
générale mais du coup ici
de manière active enfin voilà son
premier
oui parce que il y avait le problème du
fou c'est 8 que Arion essaie de gérer
avec fousser vite faut baisser petite
car il y a 5 voilà et comme ça descendre
n'est pas poussé thématique
3 je veux dire dame G3
bonne négo de l'ouverture chez Arion
c'est une bonne chose peut-être une
deuxième à KFC à certains moments voilà
bah c'est chose faite il y aura de la
main
c'est pour les normes en fait
cavaliers G4 ici et pour essayer de
garder les pièces
mais bon il y a l'autre côté un cavalier
prend B2 et tout ça et compagnie c'est
chaud
dès le début la carwana
ça commence à
des petits trucs
ça semble assez logique ici ah oui G4
donc faut G5 normal
vraiment il essaie d'échanger et changer
pour casser la dynamique de carwana
mais encore une fois en plus il y a des
changes plus les noirs sont bien en fait
à chaque fois parce que c'est un
problème
G7 mais maintenant il y a h4a5 il y a
des compensations quand même et les
ascenseurs sur la troisième rangée que
tout refroidi
en fait c'est ce qui me pose problème
du coup ton B3 ça m'a l'air bien et
parce que non seulement tu
vois et je prends
de F pour faire cap après mais moi je
venge pas enfin je préfère
c'est pas sympa
tu vois je vais essayer de
mes pièces part d'un côté peut-être que
de l'autre côté tu as le temps de faire
un truc avec ta dame avec ton cavalier
peut-être c'est pas bête et puis
j'essaie de t'embrouiller avec les trous
qu'il y a c'est très compliqué comme
position de dame B6
tu vois donc c'est intéressant de la
part de d'argent
ça c'est l'idée pour B3 c'est c'est top
quoi et puis on prend il veut garder ça
il faut jouer je pense pour éviter le
match du couloir tout le temps
[Musique]
[Rires]
ok donc du coup peut-être bouger la dame
mais c'est un peu triste de bouger un
petit ami du coup pour essayer de
ramener le subtilion à justice quand on
voulait faire complètement mesdames
mais dans ce cas là
pourquoi il n'a pas votre adresse
[Musique]
la question de prendre c'est un peu fou
mais non il y a que je voulais jouer
après mais ça marche pas
en même temps ils ont 50 secondes et
demi 10 donc vous voyez ils sont obligés
de prendre des décisions assez vite
comme comme
[Musique]
la prochaine vidéo et du coup il a
préféré défendre
quand même c'est pas si clair en fait
non c'est pas clair mais
j'aime bien A5 qui doit être un jour
faire un 4 garder sa petite scène de
pions
que j'aime bien quand même
essayez de menacer peut-être un tour
reprend un dame C3
hyper tendu
je comprends pas je comprends pas du
tout
[Musique]
compréhensible comme coup encore une
fois pour me laisser une petite case
pour un café
mais bon moi je vais partir là-haut
je reviendrai plus tard quand il sera
[Musique]
et puis voir ce qui se passe
ça c'est une menace
il a une pression il est mieux autant il
y a pas de raison de faire nul quand
même
il joue de toute façon ils aiment bien
jouer à chaque fois
ah mais il y a le petit pion B3
puis on va être en l'air
il fallait le jouer sans doute
aussi une concession qui maintenant
oblige la tour à rester ici on a eu
tellement envie de jouer H4 tout le
temps nous sauf et
un peu timide je pense qu'il est arrivé
ça veut rien dire encore alors tour des
quartiers intermédiaire sur KFC
grossiste
à la fin si on avait déjà on avait déjà
vu nos stouf ce genre de d'histoire
à son attaque jobava son début jobava ou
sa vérosoft moderne là il y aura A4
voilà tout à l'heure il a pas joué c'est
trois à quatre c'est normal et après on
menace fout des trois cavaliers 5 et de
balancer les pions tout à l'heure il
nous a fait un beau pâté là sur sur
cette partie je sais pas ce rappel sous
fait c'était pas tip top donc on va voir
c'est celle là où il s'est fait vraiment
massacrer je crois
cavalier E5
tout à l'heure il s'est fait déborder
complet à l'aile dame ouais c'est
celle-là c'est celle-là ou très très mal
tourné tu sais où il y a eu la prise en
décape et les chèques à la découverte de
marchait pas du tout
en tout cas
là on va on va pouvoir
pouvoir se remettre un petit peu dedans
là 9 8 fait plaisir
9 8 donc le 7 il est je pense que le
satellite c'est pas encore sûr s'il
gagne c'est la rapidement il peut
revenir au score oui oui oui tu fais
bien de me le dire je pense
te faire vibrer un peu là la grosse
caisse là je pense je pense pas quand
même parce qu'il fait qu'ils finissent
vite cette partie là et donc la partie
précédente là
ça y est il est chaud à nouveau quoi
mais du coup
et avant le Bullet et ben écoute
c'est très indécis au final est-ce qu'il
y a à peu près normal quand même parce
que Kawana c'est une super star on
contre qui monte à toute vitesse
c'est un défi mais ça reste quand même
ça a quand même je pense encore une fois
dans la faveur de carwana ce petit ce
petit e de parent de draguer je pense
que
le Bullet va favoriser quand même
normalement irrigasi qui est quand même
monstru ambulette et avec un point
d'avance après il peut passer plein de
choses ça va dépendre très vite ça va
très vite là ah oui il a pas fait de me
dire
on sait que c'était obligatoire de me
et que peut-être qu'ils sont fous je
sais pas
parce que là ça peut être
c'est quand même hyper dangereux dame D7
suivi B4 il y aura toujours des trois
ouais en tout cas oui
et joue avec une majorité elle dame il
est quand même un peu mieux normalement
je le pousse j'essaie de le pousser sauf
le moment
de prendre tous ces risques là
[Musique]
c'est le monde égaliser là
il reste que 3 minutes de 20 faut que ça
repartes c'est là je vois ils ont du
temps
j'aimerais bien nous
on se dépêche
[Rires]
c'est pas mal que c'est 4 qui est donc
la B4 elle va être quasiment le prochain
coup je pense très mauvais F6 ce serait
logique je pense avec les noirs pour
bloquer le projet 3 et au moins il y a
ça
ça j'ai du mal sauf pour moi F6 tempo
c'était peinard
F6 a ramené le roi ça bloqué et là il
fait il met la tour passive mais même du
B5 qui peut qui peut manger un pion donc
je sais pas trop ce qui se passe
de la fatigue chez ton poulain
je ne sais pas
il fait pas trop la gueule là
ce qui se passe alors que
en plus normalement on arrive à détecter
5 peut-être il me semble
j'avais pas pensé on attaque une pièce
contre la tour on sait que ça vaut
qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu à j'ai
l'impression qu'il nous a un petit peu
oublié tour des seins qui est en train
de presser
et là
ce que serait pas un petit peu en train
de s'inverser avec tourner
l'idée était folles avec tout reprendre
5 tours E5 tours
la qualité et faire tourner vite
incroyable tu vois il a pris tempo
ah oui c'est joli le petit roi c'est de
tempo aussi je peux te dire qu'il fait
plaisir
par moment il y a des séquences de folie
peut-être maintenant
c'est bizarre qu'il est pas joué j'étais
plus favorable avec carte mais bon ok
nouvelle peut-être ils sont fortement en
vrai ça joue tellement bien pour C4
l'idée super idée
la cloche
[Musique]
on peut jouer encore avec des Noirs
ouais il a joué
en tout cas
ça doit être nul quand même je pense pas
sûr passer hein parce que là c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle pour moi
qui est hyper combat 6 franchement qui
se qui se bat qui refuse la nulle
la fusée
c'est pas vrai ça a mal tourné cette
histoire allez on pousse elle est trois
peut-être on pousse des Caval le 5 mais
ça marchera pas
pas content un peu colère
il y a une pause il y a une pause du
coup 9 9 écoute super super score après
2e set
voilà comment tennis pour l'instant sauf
donc là du coup celui qui gagne les
prochains set et ben je t'annonce et ben
il va gagner si ce
franchement pour le Bullet je préfère
largement être représenté par contre
carwana que je veux qu'on soit amulette
je serai dans je serai malheureux
d'aller jouer les bullettes contre toi
je suis bien content qui me représente
quoi mais là du coup là du coup on
parlera après de ce qui se passe en 4
nul en cas de qualité il y a des
partages
il y a quatre parties de Bullet en cas
de départage OK et si c'est encore
égalité et ben il va y avoir un
Armageddon avec
la cadence qui va être débattue aux
enchères
c'est pas une blague
en fait on leur demande combien de temps
ils veulent donc imaginons 3 et 4 et ben
je crois que ça va être 4 c'est un truc
bizarre on m'a raconté un peu rapidement
mais pas bien compris mais c'est
qui dit mieux et ça c'est un peu bizarre
bref donc on en est pas encore là on va
voir après ce qui se passe en Bullet
après une courte page de pose
de pub aussi t'inquiète pas mais on
essaie de commenter au mieux mais c'est
vrai
et ça joue très bien effectivement
en tout cas je vous dis à tout de suite
environ environ
3 minutes je pense et on est de retour à
tout de suite
[Musique]
et on est revenu j'écoute l'arbitre
de 1 + 1 il y a juste la cadence c'est
mes 3 plus simple sera bien du 1 + 1
ouais ça va bastonner une demi-heure de
1 + 1 et si on égalité à l'issue de ce
Bullet en une plus une et ben on aura
quatre parties de Bullet et à l'issue
encore du match nul on aura un
Armageddon mais avec un système de temps
un peu différent généralement c'est 5
contre 6
les blancs qui ont 6 minutes qui doivent
gagner les noirs avec 5 qui peuvent
faire nulle mais là c'est un système
d'enchères et c'est assez bizarre et je
vous dis que le temps il est on m'a
expliqué tout à l'heure enfin hier et
j'ai pas trop bien compris mais écoutez
on verra bien on va pas expliquer
donc on voit que c'est vraiment sa
spécialité à harouny plus de 3100
alors du coup là c'est le Bullet donc
vraiment Arjun qui est qui fait du
Bullet moi je le voyais à l'époque sur
même sur sur les chaises qui fait que ça
qui fait journée à faire du Bullet c'est
assez monstrueux c'est Baptiste comment
tu vas
salut à toi
[Musique]
attention ça va aller très vite
maintenant vous voyez les joueurs ils
sont partis pour une demi-heure et ça
c'est dur ouais c'est chaud et on voit
que malgré tout tu vois que Caruana il a
quand même 3045 ambulette pour un
bleu avec une cadence en avant on a bien
expliqué un des meilleurs joueurs de
tous les temps
donc pour un joueur qui entre guillemets
mauvais en Bullet ça reste quand même un
monstre
plus vite il a un style assez agressif
assez
dynamique et pose des problèmes
rapidement
et du coup ça peut faire un peu de
style plus classique donc il y a un pion
qui a volé mais bon à cette cadence de
jeu là ça veut pas dire grand chose
on sait un avantage certain mais
au pire c'est le truc égal il y avait
tour B8 et du coup le fouet de volley
donc du coup il a quand même laissé là
attention à tourner
un coup qui peut un jour
pas maintenant il y a quand le four en
E2 c'est un G3 H4 j'ai pas du tout aimé
le G3
j'aime beaucoup les Noirs ici
[Musique]
tu as peut-être position avec Dame 5
dame G5 on peut transférer la dame et
essayer de de tenter quelque chose une
petite attaque peut-être qu'avait les B4
peut-être qu'il veut venir en dessin
échanger des pièces
c'est bien joué
blanc mais attention tour des deux OK
et à cette cadence là le roi fragile
c'est d'ailleurs elle a fait H3 pour le
roi soit fragile tout le temps même dans
la finale
pour la finale ça ça pose quand même
vachement problème
pour l'instant on dirait pas que les
mecs sont en zinote c'est hyper hyper
chaud je pense que c'est ça va être
perdu celle-là c'est trop dur h puis
c'est cadeau
lagazine il est indien il a un bien
c'est bâti
c'était pas mal
le
référentin c'était mignon B5 tu l'as dit
F3 tous défend et si tu prends un jeu
voilà c'est très très chaud je préfère
avoir les Noirs ici encore une fois j'ai
un pion de moi mais c'est qui sont
terribles et chaque fois là F4 c'est
chaud le cavalier doit rester ici pour
défendre la Casa F3
qui arrive attention
[Musique]
il a plus de temps ouais c'était très
juste
ambulette je le vois pas tomber ça peut
faire nul
on est parti pour le choix ok incroyable
cette partie déjà vos sauvetage encore
une fois de de
Caravana qui c'est clair mais je crois
que tu avais trouvé salut canard coureur
qui avait trouvé franchement stouf avec
ton B5 je crois que c'était gagnant j'ai
pas vu c'est possible encore une fois on
on suit sans ordinateur on peut pas vous
dire avec certitude ça va extrêmement
vite pour nous aussi
en B6 c'est standard il aime bien
pousser des pions loin comme ça et Gazi
il prend des cases en cas de dessin qui
aurait des casser 5 par exemple pour un
cavalier qui pourrait être pas mal j'ai
rentré dans ma position ennemi
maintenant il tape le pion des 6 tours
c'est un coup pour essayer de gagner des
cases aussi
ok prise G5
des cas donc il a raison il essaie de se
créer des cases pour ces pièces
peut-être plus 5
difficile à jouer maintenant pour
faire bien au
qui arrive chose comme ça ça sent trop
bon
qui peut arriver avec des
sacrifices mais bon j'y crois pas ça
c'est un peu
assez fort parce que là
un petit peu on arrive en train de
stream
avec l'idée d'un C7
intéressant avec l'idée des fois de
faire du cavaler combien ça comme tu
l'as dit il faut 4 cloué on peut jouer
dams est complètement fermé
le fou il sortira plus en fait toujours
très très bien Fabiano
roi là et même du cavalier
il y a pas le choix dame dessin qui
défend ici c'est de faire peur voilà ce
que j'aurais essayé de faire aussi mais
c'est clair que maintenant c'est les
noirs qui jouent pour quelque chose
il y avait dominé pendant longtemps et
là est-ce que c'est un coup ou pas
bien sûr bien sûr tu as trouvé
[Musique]
ça pourrait faire mal aussi c'est dans
une finale un moment où il y aurait un
G8
sa part et cavalière 3 avec ta main qui
peut arriver
il en a pas tenu compte
à ce niveau là je pense qu'il tient plus
pour son roi des quatre du coup peut
marcher il y a pas d'échec
je pense
attention attention
qu'est-ce qui se battent parce que
franchement mirighazi
qui avait son fou une poubelle qui a
réussi à trouver du jeu
c'est pas très mérité parce que Fabiano
avait fait une super partie et vous
voyez dans cela même à ce niveau là il a
essayé de sortir son roi pour gagner et
au final elle a perdu quoi
c'est
quand même
ça vient voilà en fait c'est un hold-up
pour moi mais ça vient pas tout seul
c'est toujours les mêmes qui arnaque
parce que bah ils sont très denses dans
la défense etc
une partie à les blancs vont pousser un
petit peu mauvais fou vous voyez donc
là on peut imaginer un petit H5 derrière
peut-être pris dans la prise c'est pas
trop
MP4 un jour qui arrivera
il a mangé et là il faut là il faut
rester il a défendu G4 parce que
peut-être prise était une menace avec
l'idée que sur ton point il y avait la
tour en l'air
maintenant ça fait toujours un quelque
chose à surveiller ouais c'est ça et là
du coup il a mangé comme ça pour laisser
enfin pour empêcher la tour de rentrer
ici et j'ai l'impression de passer
protégé quand même le roi qui défend
mais sur le long terme la finale
d'Europe par exemple sera très pénible à
défendre pour les pour les Noirs à cause
du tout moi c'est protégé
la position
donc là il essaie d'avoir du contre jeu
mais tu manges le pion
et H5 qui va pouvoir être joué un
presque d'abord et un jouet
[Musique]
pour irigalisme malheureusement
en vrai oui mais après j'ai je me suis
rappelé qu'on avait à Paris du coup en
fait au final je suis très content
avec mon temps il y a pas longtemps
et à nouveau l'égalité il y a pas de
break d'effectuer il reste 19 minutes
et on est à égalité parfaite
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe attention
repasse avec les Blancs vous voyez hein
on a fait une vidéo sur Youtube les gars
troposki vous allez voir tout
on part de cette position d'ailleurs
pas vu cette trompe pas comme quoi il
aura joué quasiment tout ce qui existe
en début du plombage
de D4S
la moitié du temps de Bullet et on est
toujours à une égalité
incroyable j'aime bien le 5 mais je suis
pas assez bon on s'apondition pour
comprendre ce qui se passe
5 peut-être en fait c'était trop trop
bon en fait ça fait plaisir après ces
cinq ah bah tiens
le 5 x 4 logique pour jouer sur casse
blanche ouais et puis je veux juste sur
sa case là et puis si tu prends tu vois
je manque avec qui va venir sur
certaines cases c'est intéressant parce
que la faute je pense que le foot doit
être échangé
et ah j'aime bien ton idée aussi de
retour G3
le roi et la bas il se dit tiens
j'aimerais bien le garder pour faire mal
alors ce qui fait qu'avant les D6 comme
il avait prévu c'était avant maintenant
il a toutes les pièces
même que c'est peut-être un coup aussi
sur le truc
[Musique]
un peu moins mais ok
la diagonale blanche qui donne des cases
ça va être la fin et là c'est maintenant
un coup
est-ce que c'est gros H8 c'est bizarre
excuse-moi
mais bon
bon là ça a été la fessée ça a été la
fessée
blanc et évidemment et avantagé parce
qu'il met la pression directement à
l'adversaire et c'est plus dur d'avoir
pression directement à cette cadence là
de une minute quoi c'est bon
un peu n'importe quoi tout de suite
comme celle-là après
franchement
complètement foutu ouais mais c'est du
Bullet et c'est compliqué
mais c'est clair que là je n'aime pas
vraiment cher de la peau des Noirs après
pour C1 à 4 le roi est complètement à
poil là il a pas l'attaque mais il fait
rien quoi donc en fait un peu plus
mentionnel je suis un peu déçu du choix
de mon poulain 3 alors attends il va
ouvrir sa tête vous voyez que ça se bat
quand même beaucoup
il y a pas d'âme c'est deux
qui est fou c'est 6 j'aime bien ce qui
fait
comment ça joue vite il faut prendre
tout reprendre
c'est quoi le coup que je vais jouer
rapidement
qui va venir taquiner
incroyable ce qui arrive
mais bon qui arrive quand même
dans cette position
[Musique]
ok
c'est hyper chaud quoi
en plus maintenant
je comprends pas
parce que honnêtement
pas tour C8 il y a tout à 8 tour à 8
semaines
dans un truc de fouet 5 j'ai tour C6
mais je peux aussi manger à 7 et joue
avec deux pièces
est perdu donc
si je pense pour échanger ouais ouais
je pense qu'il va quand même réussir à
manger des pions peut-être
c'est un petit peu embêtant le fou il a
pas 36 cases
[Musique]
qui
va faire le tour
et le roi qui monte quand même
extrêmement vite je pense déjà quatre
H7
OK
hyper chaud là le 4
ils sont juste trop fort les gars
parce que ça chauffe hein vous savez
quand vous enchaînez les bullets de les
parties c'est difficile d'être à niveau
constant
et c'est marrant Fabiano qui essaie la
petite française et regaizy joue que ça
quasiment
et
il reste 12 minutes à la pendule donc
encore le temps quand même de faire des
parties donc là on est on est je pense
qu'ils ont en train de faire encore 4 ou
5 parties
il a joué Robert tempo
t'as compris un peu il veut en venir
vous avez bien compris comment ça marche
beaucoup de violence comme certains le
voient dans le chat
des fois des positions dans la partie
précédente un moment est réalisé pour
moi il est complètement foutu puis
complètement gagnant
que j'aime bien ça aussi c'est mangeant
C3
deuxième
on sait qu'il a l'air en échange les
deux
minéraux
il y a un peu de fatigue alors attention
dame prend aussi c'est beaucoup de jeux
avec échange cavalier 4 il faut être sûr
ces deux aussi qui est arrivé
B3
grosse pression encore une fois là
grosse pression de Caravana
la super partie
qu'on a un coup comme tour B3
il y a beaucoup de temps à la pendule
quand même une belle avance de temps la
pendule il y a le 5 en l'air aussi que
j'avais pas vu
ça va vite ça va extrêmement vite
tour à 8 va être la menace
[Musique]
il y a un problème sur A2
d'un C2 même si c'est pas mal
il y en a trois
envoyer c'est limite à craquer
la raison il y a une position qui est
qui est sûrement gagnante il presse il
attend il améliore ses pièces
[Musique]
il reste pas bien mais bon
des problèmes avec les Blancs alors
qu'en plus il avait une position
complètement perdue
dont j'ai deux allez mange des pions il
sait que les que les transpositions
seront gagnantes prises
[Musique]
il reste du temps 8 minutes qui prend
l'avantage dans ce dans ce match
pour faire gagner pour faire gagner les
sébastoufs
écoute Paul c'est hyper compliqué on a
on a parié sur le on a parié sur le sur
le match et du coup Kévin a parié sur
eregasi et moi j'ai parié sur carvana
alors que je voulais moi aussi parler
sur vergazi alors pour l'instant du coup
écoutez c'est très très chaud il reste 8
minutes à la pendule et plus un de
carvana autant dire que si coriandre
s'il gagne ça
salut Cyril salut à tous
du coup F5 j'ai l'impression que erwana
est en train de faire mal en plus à
oula qui avait les prendre des cinq ça
c'était raté
oublié c'était raté mais elle a tout
elle a pas beaucoup de cases parce que
tout ressens que c'est pas forcément bon
[Musique]
l'initiative comme on a dit alors est-ce
que tu avais pensé cinq ça va être le
revers de la médaille F3
j'ai 7 pour tout rachuite attention hein
ça peut aller vite là maintenant avec
toi
il y a pas beaucoup de trucs parce que
dommage si c'est une fourchette dommage
7 j'ai échec qui avait F5 c'est pas sûr
que tu puisses vraiment faire dans ma
tête
ah oui non non ça va là maintenant
on doit être une menace peut-être penser
à faire roi et fin et là il va y avoir
[Musique]
ah non mais je comprends
je dis n'importe quoi
j'ai plein de trucs
est-ce qu'on peut aller
Dame des trois
incroyable ce qui se passe dans cette
partie là si percer
c'est pas en prise
84 c'est incroyable cette partie ah il
peut semblant si la paire parce que le
match il est assez plié là dans mes
chers
3 qui va tenir à chaque fois
attention qu'il y a quand même et Max
incroyable encore une fois
4 minutes donc 4 minutes c'est sans
doute deux parties 4 minutes 4 minutes
de parti deux parties
ouais alors du coup 12 et demi égalité
il reste deux parties je pense peut-être
trois mais non deux je pense que c'est
c'est
c'est normal
[Musique]
il en faut on se rend compte aussi de la
performance parce que le truc c'est de
rester à niveau constant pendant tout le
speedcha c'est hyper dur ils enchaîne
comme des malades là c'est hyper chaud
F5 OK
H4
il a joué G5
il met une pression énorme au temps 20
secondes H4
donc du coup trois H7 j'imagine
en fait arrêter au même moment
depuis quelques temps il a beaucoup
progressé et là il a l'impression
[Musique]
allez c'est sorti les troubles dam F3
offert des petits guilis il y a quand
même des petits échecs en C4 mais sur le
long terme tu vois quand même les Noirs
avant la paire de fou bonne structure et
je vois pas je vois pas vraiment à
perdre cette partie et je pense qu'il
peut la pousser
les oreilles pointues les cavaliers qui
vont faire mal normalement dans mes
trois là
j'ai 6 j'ai le fou maintenant c'est une
bonne nouvelle il veut pas
à cette attention
on s'en fout un peu il y a voilà il se
passe rien du tout
qui arrive aussi F4 dans
F3
un petit pressing noir pardon il y a un
pressing noir
oulala
ïe boulette le pion qui passe le roi qui
va manger métro ça sent le riz il reste
6 minutes à la pendule dernière partie
non il reste
sur toi pour ne pas perdre celle-là
il s'est trompé
je pense qu'il voulait tranquille donc
il reste 37 secondes pour cette partie
donc c'est sûrement la dernière du
tournoi sauf si sauf si argent gagne
cette partie
donc Serge gagne les gars c'était
partage donc c'est 4 parties
supplémentaires minimum
c'est pourquoi je rigole
du coup à 5
j'aime bien les blancs en plus avec
assise
ok moi je rejoins
enfermer les pièces dame 4 ça y est il
regazi qui qui
c'est parti elle a l'air dur dur pour
pour les blancs pour les Noirs
c'est le la rapidité de carwana
justement on avait dit en 5 + 5 à Rio
n'était très très rapide c'était vrai
mais là au niveau du swing il est hyper
impressionnant
pas du tout mais c'est non c'est pas du
tout ça c'est pas pour cette raison là
que je faisais la blague à Kevin
D5 donc là il doit absolument gagner ou
d'un des 6 est-ce que c'est RIP
s pourtant il a pas du tout bougé
du coup je regardais non je pense qu'il
a prévu
en tout cas il a deux pions de moins
c'est marrant parce que
le joueur qui a engrais pas d'expression
il y aurait-il pas
trois pions de moi
avec un élève 3 on joue solide attention
à la tour ici
il va pas il va pas la donner
ça a l'air dur faut F3
fou de fouet froid aussi
en dessin peut-être
déjà un petit un petit lot de
consolation et encore deux pions de plus
qu'un pour Caravana avec
une bonne gestion de la pendule oui
aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
qui est très content comme tu dis Kawana
qui se qualifie pour pour la face
supplémentaire et la phase suivante
où il aura donc je peux vous montrer qui
qui l'opposera
[Musique]
du coup qui se qualifie
la seconde phase et jouera du coup le
vainqueur de Carlsen gokeh
de finale ou pas du coup pour fêter de
la victoire souffle comment
dans le petit icône car de finale pour
fêter ta victoire parce que tu es
capable de faire ça
c'est une image qu'on que que fait comme
va la mettre à jour
belle victoire franchement c'était un
super match moi je voulais parier pour
magazine c'est toi qui a tenu à le faire
alors du coup pour
le prochain match du coup on aura dingly
Rennes contre gris Tchouk dimanche
à 17h commenté par Kevin Bordy sur la
chaîne de cheeseccom fr
donc ouais c'est un greachuk dimanche
17h par Kevin bordi donc en tout cas
merci à tous d'avoir suivi de stream
et puis et puis écoutez attendez je vais
remettre ton caméra donc merci à tous
d'avoir suivi le stream super super
match un des deux joueurs franchement
qui sont qui nous ont régalés tous
l'après-midi victoire maigre à dire de
49 Fabiana qui gagne de deux points face
à Argentine
donc nous en ce qui nous concerne tous
les deux et ben on va revenir du coup
mercredi prochain pour le match de
aronia contre André Kim
et mais sinon vous avez dimanche 17h le
match de Kevin bord divin commenté par
Kevin Bordy le match de Ding contre
plaisir qu'on vous retrouvera pour pour
ces prochains matchs c'était super en ta
compagnie sauf de comment ça c'est du
gros gros niveau vitesse incroyable des
parties de folie et des rebondissements
après ça a pas trop souri comme j'aurais
voulu tout à la fin mais c'est le jeu je
me refais je me referais souffre c'est
comme ça quel résultat alors le résultat
on peut vous montrer très rapidement
avant de avant de quitter le stream donc
karwana qui gagne 14 et demi à 12h30
alors j'ai pas les résultats ici
exactement mais je peux vous remontrer
les caméras je pense que doivent être je
pense que les caméras sont voilà bon
c'est tout déréglé ils sont partis du
coup 14 et demi 12 et demi en tout cas
pour pour Fabien
voilà voilà
c'est sympa là
technique tu t'es bien débrouillé avec
les caméras qui changent tout le temps
c'était super voilà attendez on me dit
que c'est dimanche à 14h alors pour être
avec vous j'ai pas regardé l'heure mais
comme quasiment tous les matchs sont à
17h je me suis dit que c'était seulement
17h mais je vais vérifier ça en toute 3
secondes
et je vais là c'est bien 14 heures 14
heures dimanche d'Ingrid joke c'est ça
avec Kevin Bordy dimanche 14h
cette
erreur donc je vous dis à bientôt merci
à tous d'avoir suivi le stream et puis
bonne soirée à tous
et bon courage pour ton bad
allez à bientôt ciao ciao